Do you want anything?
One second, I'm just going to...
Do you want something?
Okay.
Great.
Can I get one crispy chicken?
Two crispy chicken?
你要吃点什么吗？等一下，我只是…… 你想吃点什么吗？好吧。好吧。太好了。我可以来一份香脆鸡块吗？两份香脆鸡块？
For you, because I don't know.
You want two for yourself.
Okay.
No judgment.
That's fine.
And...
And ice cream.
Do you guys even serve...
给你点，因为我不知道你想给自己点两份。好吧。我不予评判。没关系。还有…… 冰淇淋。你们甚至还卖……
You know what?
Do you mind if we just do this after?
Welcome, it's an all-new smart list.
We were just talking about Shawshank,
and I was going to say to Will...
Jay Bortoy came on, that my philosophy in life is kind of...
Oh, this is good. Hang on.
No, this is good. This is good. You'll like that.
你知道吗？你介不介意我们待会儿再弄这个？欢迎收听，这是一档全新的 SmartLess 播客节目。我们刚才在聊《肖申克的救赎》，我正想对威尔说…… 杰·博托伊来过节目，我的人生哲学其实是…… 哦，这个不错。等等。不，这个不错。这个不错。你会喜欢这个的。
Everybody pull over and get out the pen.
By the way, this is Shawshank Redemption, I think, is for Tracy.
So the end of the movie.
So the whole movie, Morgan Freeman is talking about, like, you know, he goes in front of the,
what is it called, the panel or whatever, the people who...
Parole board.
The board.
大家都靠边停车，拿出笔来。顺便说一句，我觉得这部《肖申克救赎》是说给特雷シー听的。也就是电影的结局。整部电影里，摩根·弗里曼一直在说，你知道的，他站在那个，叫什么来着，评审团还是什么的面前，就是那些…… 假释委员会。委员会。假释委员会。
Yeah.
And he's the parole board.
And he's like, he tells them what they think they want to hear.
He's like, no, I've been reformed.
I'm good.
I've learned my lesson.
And they always deny his parole.
And then at the end of the movie,
对。而他面对的就是假释委员会。他就像是，他告诉他们他们想听的话。他说，不，我已经改过自新了。我很好。我吸取教训了。但他们总是拒绝他的假释。然后到了电影结尾，
he finally just is like, you know what, fuck it.
This is who I am.
You people are crazy.
I didn't learn anything, blah, blah, blah.
And then that's when he gets released.
That's my philosophy for life.
And that's what full release comes from honesty.
Well, two ways.
他终于觉得，去他妈的。我就是这样的人。你们这群人疯了。我什么都没学到，巴拉巴拉巴拉。然后就在那时，他获释了。这就是我的人生哲学。而这种彻底的解脱来自于诚实。嗯，有两种方式。
Sorry.
So everybody, go ahead and put your car back and drive
and toss that paper either out the window,
if you still have an ashtray in the car, use that.
Because we really didn't,
we really didn't get an end to it.
It's nice that Sean's philosophy on life is like,
you know, like, you know, don't try to be something you're not.
抱歉。所以大家，请把车挂回前进档，把那张纸从窗户扔出去，或者如果车里还有烟灰缸的话，就用那个。因为我们真的，我们真的没有得到一个结局。真好，肖恩的人生哲学就像是，你知道的，你知道的，不要试图去做一个不真实的自己。
Yeah, exactly.
Right.
I agree with you.
Authenticity is a thematic that I'm on a project that I'm working on right now.
Oh, yeah, very good.
That's the theme of the thing.
Oh, very good.
It's a great evergreen.
对，完全正确。我同意你的看法。真实性是我目前正在参与的一个项目的主题。哦，对，非常好。那是这个项目的主题。哦，非常好。这是一个永不过时的话题。
Authenticity.
Hey, Jason.
Yeah, hi.
Why did the man fall down the well?
Oh, boy.
Because he didn't see that well?
That's exactly right.
Wait, Willie, you got, when we had Jordan Peel on, his film, Nope.
真实性。嘿，杰森。对，嗨。为什么那个人会掉进井里？哦，天哪。因为他没看清那口井？完全正确。等等，威利，当乔丹·皮尔来做客时，他的电影《不!》
Yeah.
I always just thought it was just a fun way to say, yeah, no, I'm not comfortable with flying saucers.
It says the main character, and this shit freaks me out.
But it's actually an acronym for?
It's an acronym.
Well, he said it's an acronym.
And I just went, and I thought about it for two seconds,
and I went, not of planet Earth.
对。我一直以为这只是一种有趣的说法，意思是，对，不，我对飞碟感到不舒服。电影里说主角，这破玩意儿把我吓坏了。但它其实是一个缩略词？它是一个缩略词。嗯，他说这是一个缩略词。我一听，想了两秒钟，然后我说，不是来自地球。
Planet Earth.
Remember the look on his face?
He was a little mad, I think.
Well, no, what you were seeing was the same look that I had,
which is a total shock at your level of intelligence.
Yeah, just like, that was mine too.
Stunning surprise.
That's what hurt me the most was the stunning,
地球。还记得他当时脸上的表情吗？我觉得他有点生气。好吧，不，你看到的那种表情和我的一样，就是对你的智商水平感到彻底的震惊。对，就像，我也是那样。极度的惊讶。这对我伤害最大的是那种极度震惊的表情，
the stunned look on everybody's face when I do something.
Well, we're going to have a stunned look at your guest when he comes on.
Well, he's going to have a stunned look at...
Sorry, Sean. Did you have a lunch?
he's going to have a stunt look at your
when he heard your joke for sure
because he tells jokes for a living
Oh shit
每个人脸上那种震惊的表情，当我做了什么事的时候。好吧，等你的嘉宾上节目时，我们也会露出震惊的表情。好吧，他会对…… 抱歉，肖恩。你吃午饭了吗？当他听到你的笑话时，他肯定会大吃一惊，因为他可是靠讲笑话谋生的。哦，操
Yeah, here we go
And he doesn't just tell jokes
I man
He this guy tells jokes
This son of a gun
And that's kind of the language
That he would use too
对，我们开始吧 而且他不只是讲笑话 我靠 这家伙会讲笑话 这王八蛋 这王八蛋 而且这也是他会用到的那种语言
Son of a Gun
Dax Shepherds coming back
He does love son of a gun
He does
This guy uses
I don't know
There's something about
Everything that he does
王八蛋 达克斯·谢泼德又要来了 他真的很喜欢“王八蛋”这个词 他确实喜欢这家伙用…… 我不知道 他做的每一件事都有某种……
His delivery
His turn or phrase
The things he talks about
the way he does it.
A lot of people call him the nicest guy and stand-up.
I think of him as just the funniest dude.
I've seen in such a long time.
And I remember the first time I heard about him
他的表达方式 他的措辞 他谈论的事情以及他做事的方式。很多人称赞他是单口喜剧界最nice的人。我觉得他只是我见过的最搞笑的家伙。在很长一段时间里都是如此。我还记得我第一次听说他
was through our old friend, Greg Garcia.
Yeah.
And Greg was like, Greg reached out to me.
He's like, you have to have this guy on, blah, blah, blah,
and I made some glib remark.
He's like, you're going to regret it.
I go, I think he's hilarious.
Relax, Greg.
是通过我们的老朋友格雷格·加西亚。对。格雷格就像是……格雷格联系了我。他说，你一定要请这家伙上节目，巴拉巴拉巴拉，然后我开了一些肤浅的玩笑。他说，你会后悔的。我说，我觉得他很有趣。放松点，格雷格。
And then, J.B., you and I had the pleasure
of meeting him really, really briefly.
I'm going to make you repeat the glib remark right in front of him.
We met him really briefly up at last year up at Pebble Beach,
and he's as nice as he is funny, and it's all the shit.
I love this guy.
He's so funny.
I love Ray Romano.
然后，杰比，你和我去年在圆石滩有幸非常非常短暂地见过他一面。我要让你当着他的面重复那个肤浅的玩笑。我们去年在圆石滩短暂地见过他一面，他人和他的笑话一样好，而且全是扯淡。我太喜欢这家伙了。他太有趣了。我爱雷·罗马诺。
I love the Tennessee kid.
I love his new special Hello World on Amazon.
He's about to go on tour on a new one.
Guys, it's none other than the hilarious Nate Bergotsie.
Nate Braggotzi!
Even better.
I was ready for Ray.
我爱田纳西小子。我爱田纳西小子。我喜欢他在亚马逊上的新特辑《你好世界》。他马上就要带着新作品去巡演了。伙计们，他就是搞笑的内特·巴尔加齐！内特·布拉戈齐！更好。我已经准备好迎接雷了。
I love me.
I'll get Ray.
Oh, how great.
Nate, it's good to see you again.
Good to see you, Sean.
Hey, just a little fun note, never seen Shawshank.
Well, you're young.
You're too young for it.
我爱我自己。我会找雷的。哦，太棒了。内特，很高兴再次见到你。很高兴见到你，肖恩。嘿，有个有趣的小插曲，我从来没看过《肖申克》。好吧，你还年轻。你对它来说太年轻了。
You know, it's before your time.
Wait, wait.
I'm 44.
I should have.
It's pretty young.
You know what, Nate?
I didn't see Shawshank until I was 45.
Oh, I'll do it next year.
你知道的，那是你出生之前的作品。等等，等等。我44岁了。我本该看过的。这已经很年轻了。你知道吗，内特？我直到45岁才看《肖申克》。哦，我明年去看。
Anyway, Nate Bargazzi.
Nate, this is really nice.
Great to see you again, because we did meet.
We did meet up at Pebble.
Yep.
Do you live in a nice house or are you in a nice hotel room?
Where are you?
In a hotel room.
不管怎样，内特·巴尔加齐。内特，这真的很棒。很高兴再次见到你，因为我们确实见过。我们确实在圆石滩见过。是的。你住在好房子里还是在一个不错的酒店房间里？你在哪？在酒店房间里。
I'm in Syracuse.
Okay.
Working?
I get a show in Syracuse.
This is a...
Can't make it here.
Can't make it anywhere, you know?
That's what they say.
我在锡拉丘兹。好的。在工作？我在锡拉丘兹有一场演出。这是一个…… 在这里混不下去。在任何地方都混不下去，你知道吗？人们都这么说。
They don't...
That's what they say.
I like...
Nate, I like that Sean said, you said, I'm in Syracuse.
No.
He's just...
He's just hanging out with the orange man.
This is the vacations I can afford in Syracuse.
他们不…… 人们都这么说。我喜欢…… 内特，我喜欢肖恩刚才说的，你说，“我在锡拉丘兹。”不。他只是…… 他只是在和那个橘色皮肤的家伙闲逛。这就是我在锡拉丘兹能负担得起的假期。
You go, it's nice.
We took a bus up.
But it's, you know.
We spent on the hotel room.
Yeah, everything went to this.
Now, what kind of...
My family of 30 is right off camera.
They're just right there.
你说，这挺好的。我们坐大巴上来的。但你知道的。我们把钱都花在酒店房间上了。是的，全都花在这上面了。现在，什么样的…… 我那30口人的大家庭就在镜头外。他们就在那儿。
I said, if y'all talk during this, I will kill you all.
When you are traveling around and you're doing these shows,
what size is your group footprint?
What's your posse size?
We have probably like 10 guys.
Because I bring four openers.
Actually, tonight, we've got a surprise opener.
He won't be here till later.
我说，你们如果在录制时说话，我把你们全杀了。当你在各地巡演并做这些演出时，你的团队规模有多大？你的随行人员有多少？我们大概有10个人吧。因为我带了四个暖场嘉宾。事实上，今晚我们有一个惊喜暖场嘉宾。他要晚点才到。
Jimmy Fallon.
Fallon is coming to the show.
Oh, that's great.
He's going to jump on the bus.
Where do I know?
To tell me what we've been to know him from?
That movie.
Taxi.
吉米·法伦。法伦要来演出。哦，太棒了。他要跳上大巴。我怎么知道？从哪里知道他的？那部电影。出租车。
Pitch fever.
Pitch. Fever.
Taxi.
With Queen Latifah.
Yes, I remember taxi.
Jimmy right now, by the way, he's hearing this.
He's sharpening his knife hearing us say this.
《出租车女王》。发烧友。发烧。出租车。和奎恩·拉提法一起。是的，我记得《出租车女王》。顺便说一句，吉米现在正在听着呢，听到我们这么说，他正在磨刀呢。
Well, Nate, I have to say this.
We developed the show together.
years ago.
And you are very successful then.
But to see you over the years,
just kind of like,
and then SNL, and then like,
it's so exciting to finally be like,
好吧，内特，我不得不说。我们多年前一起开发了这个节目。那时你已经非常成功了。但多年来看着你，一步步走到现在，然后是周六夜现场（SNL），然后就像是…… 终于看到这种感觉太令人兴奋了，
yes, this guy has been brilliant,
has always been brilliant,
and now more and more people can see it.
And you sell, Nate, you sell out arenas
like 20,000 at a clip,
which is just unbelievable.
And on top of this,
and I'm going to say this,
是的，这家伙一直都很才华横溢，现在越来越多的人能看到了。而且内特，你的门票总是一售而空，竞技场级的演出一次就能卖出2万张，这简直难以置信. 除此之外，我要说的是，
and I really,
and I've said it a bunch since it aired
when you're on SNL,
your sketch,
your George Washington sketch
is to me, just in my opinion,
the funniest SNL sketch I've seen in 15 years.
I totally agree with that.
而且我真的，自从你上完SNL节目播出后我已经说过好多次了，你的那个短剧，你的乔治·华盛顿短剧，在我看来，仅仅代表我个人观点，是我15年来看过最好笑的SNL短剧。我完全同意这一点。
It is remarkable.
Now, your TV just went on,
which tells me that you're bored.
The family's bored.
The 30 men are getting itchy.
There's no one in here.
It's just you and Jim Benheim, right?
我完全同意这一点。这太非凡了。现在，你的电视突然自己打开了，这告诉我你无聊了。家人也无聊了。那30个人开始坐立不安了。这里没别人。只有你和吉姆·本海姆，对吧？
Is that his name?
Jim and turn it off or doesn't matter.
No, no, it's give me something to watch.
But you have, to echo what Sean's saying,
And you have just like kind of finally, thankfully, thankfully the rest of America is just like
understand what an awesome, awesome, hilarious dude you are.
So how do you start?
You're the Tennessee kid.
那是他的名字吗？吉姆，把它关掉，或者无所谓。不，不，这能给我提供点消遣。但正如肖恩所说，你终于、谢天谢地，谢天谢地，全美人民终于开始明白你是一个多么棒、多么了不起、多么搞笑的家伙了。那你刚开始是怎么做喜剧的？你是田纳西小子。
You're from Old Hickory, Tennessee.
Am I right about that?
Yes.
Old Hickory.
Is it next to New Hickory?
No.
News is a little bit farther.
Was it ever New Hickory?
你是田纳西州老山核桃镇人。我没记错吧？是的。老山核桃镇。它挨着新山核桃镇吗？不。新山核桃镇要远一点。它曾经叫过新山核桃镇吗？
No.
He's got this great joke in his new special on Amazon Prime where he says I'm from old Hickory's
where Andrew Jackson's from and people are like, he wasn't a good guy.
and Nate goes, well, we didn't know them that well,
but we didn't know them at all.
It's hilarious joke.
But Nate, talk to me about when you were a kid and stuff,
like, did you always into comedy?
没有。他在亚马逊Prime的新特辑里有一个超棒的笑话，他说我来自老山核桃镇，也就是安德鲁·杰克逊的老家，然后人们会说，他可不是个好人。内特就说，嗯，我们跟他没那么熟，其实我们根本不认识他。这是个极其搞笑的笑话。但内特，跟我聊聊你小时候的事吧，比如，你一直对喜剧感兴趣吗？
Did you watch SNL? Like, what were your inspiration?
That's what I was thinking. That's what I was getting to.
How did you start?
I just got there faster.
It's, uh, I grew, my dad's a magician.
What?
And does comedy. Mine too.
Mine can disappear on the drop of a hat.
你看周六夜现场吗？比如，你的灵感来源是什么？我刚才就在想这个。我正要说到这儿。你是怎么开始的？我只是更快地到达了那里。我……我爸是个魔术师。什么？而且还表演喜剧。我爸也是。我爸一转眼就能消失得无影无踪。
Sean Hayes. You are talk show quick.
Get out of here.
Sorry, Nate.
Thanks, you guys. Keep going.
No, I mean, I grew up around that.
I mean, so that was like, you know, I was funny,
but then also growing up around, you know, my dad being a magician.
You learned patter.
肖恩·海斯。你接话的速度真快谈话节目主持人的料。滚开。抱歉，内特。谢谢你们，伙计们。继续。不，我的意思是，我在那种环境下长大的。所以这就好像是，你知道的，我挺搞笑的，但也因为在那种环境中长大，你知道的，我爸是个魔术师。你学会了即兴顺口溜。
Yeah, it just kind of leads you to it, I guess.
Wait, wait, wait, so Nate, so you grew up, your dad's magician.
He obviously loved you.
Sorry, Sean.
And he, I mean, to the extent that he wanted to stick around.
I'm friends with Sean's dad.
Yeah.
Oh, so you know where he is.
是的，我想这自然而然地就把你引向了这条路。等等，等等，等等，所以内特，你长大的时候，你爸爸是个魔术师。他显然很爱你。抱歉，肖恩。而且他……我是说，出于他想要留在你身边的程度来看。我和肖恩的爸爸是朋友。对。哦，所以你知道他在哪。
Yeah, yeah, he's a pretty good dude.
I got it.
Yeah.
I don't know the whole backstory, but I know.
I just know from what our hanging out is.
He's got no tread left on his tires, but he's a good guy.
He checks you a pin to his location.
So what was that like growing up with your dad being a magician?
对，对，他是个挺不错的家伙。我知道。对，我不知道全部的内情，但我知道。我只是根据我们一起玩时的了解。他轮胎上的花纹都快磨光了，但他是个好家伙。他会给你发一个他的实时位置定位。那么，在一个魔术师父亲身边长大是什么体验？
That's pretty rad.
An illusionist.
Yeah, yeah, it was the best.
You know, I don't know if I even understood it.
Like, I'm sure, I think of it like my daughter and I'm sure your kids.
Like, it doesn't seem not normal.
Like, it just felt like it's like, that's all I ever knew.
And it wasn't until you got older that you're like,
那挺酷的。一个幻觉魔术师。对，对，那是最好的体验。你知道的，我甚至不知道自己当时是否真的理解。就像，我确信，我想象我和我女儿的关系，我确信你对你的孩子也是这样。这看起来并不不正常。就像，这感觉就像，这就是我所知道的全部。直到你长大了，你才会觉得，
yeah, dude, nobody's dead's a magician.
Yeah.
Start saying you don't know when you're asked what your dad does.
Right.
Yeah.
So he would make a living room.
I mean, I have people do magic.
Like, magicians would show me magic trick.
对啊，老兄，根本没有人老爸是魔术师的。对。开始在别人问你你爸是干什么的时候假装不知道。对。是的。所以他会把客厅弄得……我的意思是，我让人表演魔术。比如，魔术师会给我表演魔术。
I've just seen them all, too.
And I'm just not a good, I'm not a good person to perform for it
because I'm just like, all right.
You know, it's like, is this your card?
You're like, it's always my card.
It's always been my card.
Every time I see magic, every time I see magic,
I freaking love it.
我也全都见识过了。而且我不适合当观众，我不适合当他们的表演对象，因为我只会想：行吧。你知道的，就像，这是你的牌吗？你会觉得：永远是我的牌。这永远都是我的牌。每次我看魔术，每次我看魔术，我都爱死它了。
And I'll bet everybody listening loves it.
I mean, how can you not love when you see a magic trick?
I mean, a good one, if it's convincing.
But I never think about it.
I never, and I always make fun of it when I hear about it.
It's like you hear about mimes.
But you know what?
You can't take your eyes off a mime or a magician.
我敢打赌所有听节目的每个人都爱它。我的意思是，当你看到一个魔术时，怎么能不爱呢？我的意思是，一个好的魔术，如果它足够令人信服的话。但我从来不去想它。我从来不去想，而且每次听到魔术我都会嘲笑它。就像你听到哑剧一样。但你知道吗？你就是无法把视线从哑剧演员或魔术师身上移开。
It gets a bad rap.
You can't take your eyes off a line.
Yeah, that's the quote of the day.
Wait, so Nate, so your dad,
Sean was going to ask this.
So your dad made a living.
as a magician.
He was a teacher, too.
它名声不太好。你就是无法把视线从哑剧演员身上移开。对，这就是今日金句。等等，所以内特，你爸爸，肖恩刚才正要问这个。所以你爸爸是以魔术为生的。他也是个老师。
So he had a day job, and then he would do that.
And then we were always in Nashville,
and so he's just always done it.
And, I mean, he's very successful,
he's very known in the magic world.
Really?
He comes with me and opens for me a lot on the road.
And he will do these shows.
所以他有一份白天的工作，然后他会做魔术表演。而且我们一直住在纳什维尔，所以他一直都在做这个。而且，我的意思是，他非常成功，在魔术界非常知名。真的吗？他经常跟我一起去，在巡演中为我做暖场嘉宾。他会做这些表演。
And, you know, it's every little boy's dream.
Travel to your dad when you're 44 years old.
So you go, got a little CPAP machine hooked up in a tour bus.
It's a good time.
You got some ramps on the side of that stage?
Yeah.
I mean, we had her bus parked out one time,
and it was my dad, my mom, and my aunt.
而且，你知道的，这是每个小男孩的梦想。44岁时和爸爸一起去巡演。所以你会说，巡演大巴里连着一个小型CPAP（持续气道正压通气）呼吸机。那真是段好时光。你舞台旁边还备有坡道吗？对。我的意思是，有一次我们的巴士停在外面，里面有我爸爸、我妈妈和我阿姨。
And I was like, people probably go by this tour bus,
and they're like, it's pretty rocking in there.
And I mean, we got, it's lights off, quiet,
just the roar of machines keeping everybody alive.
And the smell of liniment.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
Wait, so did you ever perform in the magic shows with your dad?
然后我想，人们路过这辆巡演大巴时可能会想，里面一定很摇滚吧。我的意思是，里面灯全关着，安安静静的，只有维持大家生命的机器轰鸣声。还有风湿药油的气味。对。嗯哼。等等，那你有没有和爸爸一起在魔术表演中演出过？
I did some, yeah.
I would help them with magic.
You ever get cut in half?
No, no, we didn't ever do that.
that. He never did that go that for. He just a slight hand. A lot of slight a hand and he does
comedy with it. Oh, that's my favorite. Yeah. So then when you, what age were you when you were like,
actually kind of to what Jason, you kind of alluded to it, but did you start just like being a wise
ass on the side of your dad's stage while he was doing magic? Like, is that how stand-up started
我做过一些，对。我会帮他变魔术。你有没有被切成两半过？不，不，我们从没做过那个。他从没做到过那种地步。他只会玩扑克牌戏法。大量的纸牌戏法，并且他会在其中加入喜剧元素。哦，我最喜欢这个了。对。所以当你在……你多大年纪的时候，就像杰森刚才暗示的那样，你开始在爸爸表演魔术时，在舞台旁边当起了一个满嘴俏皮话的机灵鬼？单口喜剧就是这样开始的吗？
for you? Uh, I think it was just being funny. We would, like, I remember seeing stand-up. It was just
trying to, it was trying to make people laugh. I don't think I ever really made.
fun of anybody.
Right.
But it was like I would make fun of myself a lot,
which is what I do now in my comedy.
It'd be like, you'd be doing stuff like that,
making fun of it.
呃，我想那只是因为我挺搞笑的。我们会……我记得我看过单口喜剧。这只是为了逗人笑。我想我从没有真正去嘲笑过任何人。对。但就像我会经常自嘲一样，这也是我现在在喜剧中一直在做的事。你会做类似的事情，去拿这个开玩笑。
He had, I mean, one time,
I've talked about us in a special on one of them,
but it was like he brought the Easter Bunny home
when I was like six.
He was at the mall doing a show.
And the Easter Bunny needed a ride home.
And my dad goes,
I'll give you a ride home if you swing by my house.
他有一次……我在某个特辑里谈过这件事，大约在我六岁的时候，他把复活节兔子带回家了。他在商场里做演出。然后复活节兔子需要搭车回家。我爸就说，如果你顺便来我家，我就让你搭车回家。
And so I remember the Easter Bunny,
we had like, my parents had this old red,
Mazda, stick shift, you know, and the Easter Bunny's head was bent to the side, because his head
couldn't fit in the car.
Sure.
So he was just, he was sitting like this.
And then he got out, and I met the Easter Bunny.
And then my dad drove the Easter Bunny home.
所以我记得复活节兔子……我们家有一辆老旧的红色马自达手动挡汽车，你知道的，复活节兔子的头是歪向一边的，因为它的头塞不进车里。当然。所以它只能那样坐着。然后它下车了，我见到了复活节兔子。接着我爸开车把复活节兔子送回家了。
So that started your, the Easter Bunny, you say, say, started.
That was the, yeah, that was the trajectory.
I go, all right.
I go, if I could beat that guy, then maybe I can make it as.
Now, what, what was your mom's, um, uh, uh, attitude on?
on her husband's career.
My parents have been together since seventh grade.
And they, my mom's very funny.
所以那是你的……复活节兔子，你说是……那是起点。那就是，是的，那是发展轨迹。我说，好吧。我说，如果我能打败那个家伙，那也许我能在喜剧界混出名堂。现在，你妈妈对她丈夫的职业是什么态度？我父母从七年级就在一起了。我妈妈非常幽默。
But she worked at a bank.
I mean, she's just been, I mean, it's just stuff.
There's like, growing up, it's buying, you know,
she has to go up.
My dad would be like, go to the store.
I need you to buy 12 lemons.
And he has to buy for, like, his magic
are a bunch of newspapers from that day.
但她在银行工作。我的意思是，她一直都在……也就是各种琐事。比如在成长过程中，就是买……你知道的，她不得不去……我爸会说：去商店。我需要你买12个柠檬。他需要为他的魔术买当天的厚厚一叠报纸。
It's like a bunch of random,
and it's just normal conversation.
You're just, like, it's a Tuesday.
You're just trying to grab some bread, milk, and 30 oranges,
and then you get on out of there.
And handkerchiefs in six colors.
He's got a lot of shows this week.
It's just stuff like that.
就像是一堆乱七八糟的东西，这只是很平常的对话。你就像是在一个周二，只想顺便买点面包、牛奶和30个橙子，然后赶紧离开。还要六种颜色的手帕。他这周有很多演出。就是类似这样的杂事。
That's cool.
Wait, so Nate, so I want to kind of get, again,
we're the worst interviewers on the planet.
We were just voted.
Worst ever interviewers.
We nailed it.
Of all the time.
Yeah.
这太酷了。等等，内特，所以我想了解一下……再次声明，我们是地球上最烂的主持人。我们刚刚被评选为。史上最烂采访者。我们实至名归。有史以来最烂的。对。
But I want to go back because we, again,
because you play these huge arenas,
and it's amazing.
And I don't,
I don't know if I've ever seen a comic so comfortable.
You make it so intimate, even though you're playing a huge...
There's something about it that makes it so personal and you're so organic.
Yeah, you draw us in as opposed to ask for...
但我想要倒回刚才的话题，因为我们……因为你在这些巨大的竞技场演出，这太惊人了。我不知道我是否见过哪个喜剧演员能这么放松。你把它变得如此亲密，尽管你在一个巨大的场馆里演出……某种特质让它变得如此个人化，而且你表现得那么自然。对，你把我们吸引了进去，而不是去索取……
And we're talking about authenticity.
You're very authentic.
But you...
That feels like that you...
When you started, you must have started in clubs, like in smaller venues, right?
Like most comics, I imagine.
Oh, yeah.
So I moved to Chicago first for a couple of years, and then I moved to New York.
我们在谈论真实性。你非常真实。但你……感觉好像你……当你刚开始时，你一定是从俱乐部开始的，比如在更小的场地，对吧？就像大多数喜剧演员一样，我想。哦，对。所以我先去了芝加哥呆了几年，然后搬到了纽约。
and I was in New York for the most for like eight and a half years.
And so I did all the clubs and all the like going up every single night.
I performed for one guy once.
Oh my gosh.
No way.
Like he wouldn't leave.
We tried to get him to leave and he's like, nah, it's all right.
And you're like, we don't think it's all right.
我在纽约待了差不多八年半。所以演遍了所有的俱乐部，经历过每晚都登台表演的日子。我曾经只为一个人表演过。哦，天哪。不会吧。就像他死活不肯走。我们试图让他离开，而他说：“不，没关系。”你会想：“我们觉得一点都不好。”
He really wasn't about him.
You're like, I don't want to stand up in front of a guy.
Regularly up in front of four people, five, six.
Like, I mean, six people was like, got a pretty good show going on.
You were excited about six.
No way.
Yeah.
So you just get used to just being in these kind of like, you know,
他真的不是为了自己。你会想：我才不想在一个观众面前说单口相声呢。经常就是在四个人、五个人、六个人面前表演。我的意思是，有六个人就觉得：“今晚的演出还不错嘛。”你居然会为六个人感到兴奋。不会吧。是的。所以你慢慢习惯了在这些……
it takes a long time before you're in front of like an actual pain crowd that's good.
But what does that do for you, what does that do for your like rhythm-wise,
et cetera when you're just doing six people?
Well, I had to learn to get people into my rhythm very quickly.
So since I'm talk slower and I was from South and all this,
I had to figure out, because I would follow like high-energy acts.
And then I'd come up and I'm like, well, I got to come up with this.
joke or I gotta say something.
要花很长时间，你才能在真正买票且氛围良好的观众面前演出。但这能为你带来什么？在节奏感等方面，当你只面对六个人表演时，这对你有什么帮助？好吧，我不得不学会非常迅速地把人们带入我的节奏中。因为我语速较慢，而且我来自南方诸如此类的原因，我必须找出应对方法，因为我通常会排在高能量的表演后面登台。然后我走上台，心想：“好吧，我得想出这个笑话，或者我得说点什么。”
I just need you to hear my voice for a second
so you can go like, all right, readjust
and be like, now we're in this rhythm
and then get into the first kind of,
you know, come up with a good, like, opening
little thing or whatever and just
and get rolling. You know what always blows
my mind about stand-ups though, like how you can
我只需要你听我的声音一秒钟，这样你就能调整状态，心想：“好吧，重新调整，现在我们进入了这个节奏，”然后切入第一种……你知道的，想出一个不错的开场小段子或者其他什么，然后就开始渐入佳境了。不过，你知道什么总是让我对单口喜剧感到震惊吗？就是你怎么能
just walk around the stage for
two hours and always
have something to talk about
and show, like how do you, is
it like a monologue you memorize
or like how can you just
go up and speak
God, he's going to love show business, do you think?
在舞台上随便走来走去两个小时，却总是有话说，展现出……比如你是怎么做到的？这是一个你背熟了的独白，还是说你怎么能直接上台开口讲……天哪，他以后一定会爱上娱乐圈的，你觉得呢？
Yeah, Sean.
Wait, do you get a load of her.
He's going to love show business.
He's going to love it.
Two-thirds of the planet is water.
There's a couple of poles.
No, you know what I mean?
That always blows.
对，肖恩。等等，你听听她说的。他会爱上娱乐圈的。他会爱得不行的。地球表面三分之二都是水。还有几个极地。不，你知道我的意思吗？这总是让我……
Obviously, you had material that you work on,
but do you ever like...
There's your answer.
Go up and you're like, oh my God,
I don't know what's subject to talk about next?
Like the flow of...
Well, I don't go up.
Yeah, I go up prepared.
显然，你有一些精心打磨的素材，但你有没有过……这就是你的答案。上台后心想：“哦天哪，我不知道接下来该聊什么话题了？”就像那种流畅度……好吧，我上台时不是那样的。是的，我是带着准备上台的。
I mean, I can't do the other...
I can't really do, like, crowd work,
could go up and so it's very very free-tiling bro no i know but it's gonna work it on it for months i know
but nate do you ever switch it Nate do you ever switch the order uh based on the audience oh yeah
this this this new hour i've switched it a ton but it's it's worked because now i'm opening on a
joke that uh i have closed on so it's like it's great to be opening on a joke that i've
actually had to have the energy and the rhythm of a closer and then you just move it up and now it's
the front and you're doing those decisions on the fly
我的意思是，我做不到那种……我真的做不到现场即兴互动，走上台然后完全随性发挥，兄弟。不，我知道，但我已经为它排练几个月了。我知道，但内特，你有没有根据观众实时调整顺序？哦，会啊，这个全新的一个小时的节目里，我调整了无数次。但它效果很好，因为我现在用一个我以前用来做收尾的笑话来开场。所以这感觉很棒，用一个我本需要压轴的高能量和好节奏才能驾驭的笑话来开场，然后你把它提到前面，你得在飞行中做出这些决定。
Yeah, you just fill it out.
It's like, I mean, it's kind of like a song.
Like, I'm in love with stand-up right now.
Like, I love it so much.
And it's, uh, the way I've looked at writing kind of is like, uh, it's a movie.
So I'm the main character of this movie.
And I'm not, I'm telling the story.
I'm not, there's a, you know, a reason for be saying all this stuff.
对，你得去感受现场。这就有点像一首歌。就像，我目前对单口喜剧正处于热恋中。我太喜欢它了。而且，我对写作的看法有点像是一部电影。所以我是这部电影的主角。我在讲一个故事。我不是……所有这些话都有我这样说的原因。
And everything leads into the other thing.
Yeah.
So you want to make it where people don't realize you're into another joke.
But in my head, I could be on like joke,
five. But you're trying
I'm trying to make it where like
and then that's how you remember it because the only way
you know if you're talking about like riding a car
每一件事都自然地过渡到下一件事。是的。所以你要做到让人们甚至没有意识到你已经切入了另一个笑话。但在我脑海里，我可能已经在讲第五个笑话了。但你在努力……我在努力做到让人们觉得，然后这就是你记住它的方式，因为你唯一的线索是如果你在谈论骑车，
and then you're like my wife bought a car
well now that's the only thing I could go
into. Right, right.
And we will be right back.
And now back to the show.
Who was your main inspiration
as far as developing that style
of telling stories as opposed to jokes?
然后你说“我妻子买了一辆车”，好吧，那这就成了我唯一能接下去的话题。对，对。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。在发展这种讲故事而非单纯讲笑话的风格方面，谁对你的启发最大？
Was it like a George Carlin?
Because I seem to remember he was
kind of like that too, right?
Yeah, well, a big, Cosby was one.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But, like, if you go, like, watch his old stuff, it was, it's very storytelling and all that kind of stuff.
I'm a big Seinfeld fan.
Seinfeld was, he was, I kind of think, because I always looked like I tell stories, but in a joke form.
是像乔治·卡林那样的人吗？因为我依稀记得他也是那种风格，对吧？是的，嗯，很大程度上，比尔·科斯比算一个。哦，对，对，对。但是，如果你去看他以前的作品，那是非常注重讲故事以及所有这些类型的素材。我是个狂热的宋飞迷。宋飞，他……我有时觉得，因为我看起来总是在讲故事，但却是以笑话的形式。
Like, so it's, I mean, I try to never be too far from the laugh, because the farther you are from a laugh, the bigger the laugh has to be.
And I don't want to put that much pressure on a laugh.
So if I can just kind of keep it.
That's interesting.
Going and let it build, it's like, you know, it doesn't,
you're just not putting the weight of the world on this.
You're like, you know, because if you go silent too long,
I mean, there's a point where you're like,
所以，我的意思是，我尽量让笑话不离笑点太远，因为你离笑点越远，那个笑号就必须得越大。我不想给一个笑点施加那么大的压力。所以如果我能一直保持这种状态。这很有趣。让它不断推进，这就好像是，你知道的，它不会……你不会把整个世界的重量都压在这个笑话上。你会想，你知道的，因为如果你沉默太久，我的意思是，会有那么一刻你会觉得，
well, this joke better be unreal.
Sean tried stand up, and we won't get to his opening joke,
but he was, he started so far from the laugh,
and then he never got even to the same area code as the laugh.
You know what I mean?
Like, he never, he never had actual direct sight on the laugh.
They never got a,
He went right.
好吧，这个笑话最好能惊为天人。肖恩尝试过单口喜剧，我们就不提他的开场笑话了，但他当时……他离笑点的距离太远了，而且他甚至从来没有进入过和笑点同一个区号的范围。你知道我的意思吗？就像，他从来没有……他从来没有真正直接瞄准过笑点。他们从来没有……他走偏了。
He turned into a lecture.
And there's no way.
You're like, no, he's supposed to go.
Well, he'll never get here now.
Even with a series of mirrors, he couldn't see the laugh.
It was so obscured.
That's how I drive around town.
I only take right hand turns.
他变成了一场学术讲座。根本没戏。你会想：“不，他本该去……”好吧，他现在永远也到不了那儿了。就算用上一连串镜子，他也看不到笑点在哪。被遮挡得太厉害了。我平时在城里开车就是这样的。我只向右转。
But Nate, biggest bombing story?
Like, did you just like, oh my God, this is the worst?
Yeah.
Yeah, there's a bunch.
I mean, you'd blame it on.
I had one one time.
I thought it was the shirt I wore.
And so I'd prove that shirt away.
但是内特，你最惨的砸场经历是什么？比如你有没有觉得：“哦天哪，这简直糟透了？”是的。是的，有很多次。你会把它归咎于……我曾经有过一次。我以为是因为我穿的那件衬衫。于是我把那件衬衫扔了。
I had a buttoned down shirt and I tucked it in.
I've never done that since.
Real?
Yeah.
I was like, it wasn't me.
I was just like,
this shirt.
Yeah.
我当时穿了一件系扣衬衫，而且把下摆扎进裤子里了。我从那以后再也没那样穿过。真的吗？对。我当时就想，这不是我的问题。我只是觉得是这件衬衫的错。对。
This fucking shirt is killing me.
What is this guy's shirt?
What is this guy's deal?
I've done a cruise ship.
Say no more.
Yeah, I won a contest and your prize was to set your career back five years and do cruises.
And so I go out and I'm doing it.
And you got to do like, you got to do a bunch of shows.
这破衬衫把我害惨了。这家伙的衬衫是怎么回事？这家伙到底什么毛病？我在邮轮上表演过。别说了。是的。我赢得了一个比赛，而你的奖品是让你的职业生涯倒退五年，去邮轮上表演。所以我上台去表演。你得表演很多场。
So you do 30 clean, 30 dirty.
I never had dirty.
So it's like I couldn't even,
and then you would do one, another show.
So you needed, honest,
because sometimes these people
would come back and watch multiple shows.
So you needed to have,
所以你得演30分钟干净的，30分钟带颜色的。我从来没有带颜色的段子。所以这就好像我甚至无法……然后你还得演另一场，又一场演出。所以你需要，说实话，因为有时这些人会回来观看多场演出。所以你需要拥有，
you know, two hours of material
or do crowd or be able to mess with the crowd or something.
And I remember we go up
and you would do one show
at the beginning of it.
You do like five minutes each
and it's kind of just like,
it's in the big theater
你知道的，两小时的素材，或者能够与观众互动，或者能够和观众开玩笑什么的。我记得我们上台时，你在演出刚开始时得表演一场。每个人大概演五分钟，这感觉就像是……它在一个大剧院里，
and you're kind of just letting the crowd know,
we're comedians, we've got a show back here, blah, blah.
So the other guy,
just was great and knew how to like,
he shined a fly shot on the crowd,
like just knew how to like really play with the crowd.
Always works.
And he was like, coming to my shows,
你只是在让观众知道，我们是喜剧演员，我们在后台有一场演出，巴拉巴拉。所以另一个家伙，表现得棒极了，他知道如何……他在观众身上闪烁着全场瞩目的光芒，就像……他真的知道如何与观众互动。这总是管用。然后他说：“来我的演出吧，
every show is different.
And he like made a big announcement out of they're all different.
And then I went up and I said,
my,
I go come to one.
It may be the other one,
but the other one will be the same.
I had to like,
每场演出都不一样。”他大声宣布他们的演出场场不同。然后我上台后我说，我的……我接着说：“来我的一场演出吧。可能会是另一场，但另一场会和这场一模一样。”我不得不像这样，
I was like,
do not come to all my shows.
Most will be the same.
I don't have enough material
to have them all be different.
So you can go to his shows.
They will be different.
Mine will be, and then I went and did a show, and it was, I started it, and, like, they didn't laugh, and I was like, oh, these people have been to every show.
我当时说：“千万别来看我所有的演出。大部分都会是一样的。我没有足够的素材让每一场都不一样。所以你们可以去他的演出。他的会不一样。我的会是……”然后我下去做了一场演出，结果是，我刚开始讲，然后，他们根本不笑，我就想：“哦，这些人已经看过前面所有的演出了。”
And I'm not a crowdwork guy, you know, and I'm like, so what do you do, man?
And, you know, some guys, like, I'm an, he's an oil rigor in the ocean.
It's actually a pretty crazy job.
And I was like, that's cool and I just moved on.
It's like an insane.
People are saying crazy stuff that I got my bank robber.
That's neat, man.
What about you, ma'am?
而且我不是那种擅长现场互动的喜剧演员，你知道的，所以我当时就问：“那么你是做什么的，老兄？”然后，你知道的，有些家伙会说：“我是海洋上的石油钻井工人。”这其实是一份挺疯狂的工作。然后我说：“那挺酷的，”然后我就切过去了。这简直太疯狂了。人们说着各种疯狂的话，而我说：“我是个银行劫匪。”这挺酷的，老兄。你呢，女士？
I had nothing.
No riffing.
And then I had a ride in an elevator with these people.
I'm in the elevator in the ocean.
You think it sounds like I made it.
And I'm just sitting there and I had a hat on and I just hear some guy just
trashing me and I'm, my shoulders touching him.
And I just have to sit there and get off.
我什么也接不上。完全没法现挂。然后我和这些人一起坐了电梯。我在大洋上的电梯里。你听起来可能会觉得我已经成功了。我当时就坐在那儿，戴着帽子，然后我听到有个家伙一直在喷我，我的肩膀都快碰到他了。而我只能坐在那儿，等着出电梯。
But they do separate them between clean and dirty on a cruise ship.
That's exclusive to a cruise ship?
Yeah, you would just have a show that's like the kids can come to this show,
your family can come to this show.
and then you'd have like a night at, you know, 11 p.m.'s like adult-only show.
Yeah.
You still can't be that dirty, but it's the idea of it is a little more, you know.
Yeah, you could have just dropped in a couple F-bombs just randomly.
不过在邮轮上，他们确实把干净的演出和带颜色的演出分开了。这是邮轮独有的吗？对，你会有那种小孩子也能看的演出，全家人都能看的演出，
I got a curse as I talk about parking.
I'm like, you guys have a parallel park and they're like, this guy's filthy.
Yeah, I didn't even have it.
I didn't even have, I had no dirty jokes.
Like, there's no, I don't really, I don't talk about sex or, like, political.
Like, there's nothing like really like that's kind of like this.
about political sex. Will you ever touch political sex? Is that something that you'd be willing to do?
Yeah. If the right joke comes up. Sure, sure. You know, it is funny, it is remarkable how
然后还会有那种晚上11点开始的成人专属演出。对。你其实还是不能太荤，但它的概念会更……你知道的。对，你本可以随便飙几句脏话的。我一谈到停车就会忍不住骂脏话。我会说：“你们这些家伙会侧方停车吗？”他们就会觉得：“这家伙太粗俗了。”对，我甚至都没有那种。我甚至连……我没有一个带颜色的笑话。比如，没有，我其实不谈论性，或者……政治。没有那种真正类似……关于政治和性的话题。你以后会涉及政治或性的话题吗？那是你愿意去尝试的吗？会啊。如果有合适的笑话出现的话。当然，当然。你知道的，这很有趣，令人惊叹的是
how clean your stand-up is. And a lot of people, it's such a weird thing to have to say to point it out,
but I guess it is worthy of pointing out. And it is, to me, such a testament to how profoundly funny
you are. And honestly, and I hope it is a badge of honor for you. It should be, because it really,
you find ways to talk about stuff
and you don't need to swear it.
I swear like a...
Cosby never cursed.
Famously.
你的单口喜剧是多么干净。很多人会觉得，指出这一点是一件很奇怪的事，但我想这确实值得一提。而且，在我看来，这充分证明了你是多么深刻地幽默。说实话，我希望这能成为你的一个荣誉勋章。它本该如此，因为真的，你总能找到方法去讨论各种话题，而不需要爆粗口。我满嘴脏话，像个……科斯比从不爆粗口。出了名的。
Well, again, let's not try to, you know, look at it,
so let's not...
No, let's go down the avenue of Cosby and Clean, you know?
Yeah.
This guy...
So, Nate, wait, did you...
So at home, what's it like at home?
So, like, is your...
好吧，话说回来，让我们不要试图去……回顾那些，所以我们不要……不，让我们别走科斯比和“干净”这条道了，好吗？对。这家伙……所以，内特，等等，你……在家里是什么样的？所以，比如你的……
Do you check out...
Do you run jokes by your wife?
Does she okay them?
Is she sick of hearing them?
like what is that dynamic at home?
I'll tell her.
Yeah, she knows about every joke that comes up
because that's something I had to learn
你会……你会跟妻子对笑话吗？她会通过吗？她听腻了吗？比如那里的家庭动态是怎样的？我会跟她讲。是的，她知道每一个新出来的笑话，因为这是我不得不学会的一点，
to when you make fun of your wife at the beginning
is you have to show love.
Like you have to show, because people,
because I remember at the beginning of the reaction
would be like, well, why are you married?
And so then you're like, well, that's not what I want.
You don't need to have that reaction.
So you have to then make fun of yourself,
当你在开头的段子里拿你妻子开玩笑时，你必须表现出爱意。比如你必须表现出来，因为人们……因为我记得刚开始时大家的反应会是：“好吧，那你为什么还要结婚？”然后你就会想：“好吧，这不是我想要的反应。”你不需要那种反应。所以你必须转而去嘲笑你自己，
but with her and you've got to do it in a way
that where they can tell that you do love your wife.
You love your family and you, you know.
And so it's just kind of like just making fun of each other.
But, yeah, I'll run by stuff.
But that comes across, and you do that bit about the guy coming to replace a water heater
and your other special.
And you go, finally the guy realizes you don't know what you're talking about.
但是要带上她，你必须以一种让大家能看出你确实深爱着你妻子的方式来做。你爱你的家人，而且你……你知道的。所以这有点像互相开玩笑。但是，是的，我会跟她对一下段子。但这效果很好，你在另一个特辑里讲了那个关于有人来换热水器的段子。你说，最后那个人终于意识到你根本不知道自己在说什么。
He thinks maybe this is a modern relationship.
And he says to me, is your husband here?
And then you go, yeah, I think she's here somewhere.
It's so good.
And it is, like you said, you're self-deprecating.
you're the you're the
the butt of the joke which I think is
always such a winning combo
他觉得这也许是一种现代婚姻。他对我说：“你丈夫在家吗？”然后你回答：“对，我想她大概在某处吧。”这太棒了。而且，正如你所说，你非常自嘲，
you're not making fun of somebody
you're not having a laugh at somebody else's
expense you're not putting somebody else down
to make yourself
funny which is great
yeah I just never liked it like I felt bad
I mean I'll like make fun my buddies
and comics and stuff
你是……你是笑话里被开玩笑的对象，我认为这绝对是一个无敌的组合。你不是在取笑别人，你不是踩着别人的痛脚来搞笑，你不是通过贬低别人来让自己显得好笑，这真的很棒。对，我一直都不喜欢那样。我觉得很糟糕。我的意思是，我会拿我的哥们儿和喜剧演员朋友开玩笑，
but in the audience you just I just always felt
you know it's like this person just trying to sit there
they don't need it
yeah yeah yeah like big what's your shit
your shirt's stupid.
And then I got my shirt on tucked in.
Right?
Don't we all got stupid shirts?
但对台下的观众，你只会……我总觉得，你知道的，这个人只是在静静地坐在那里，他们不需要这个。对，对，对，就像：“嘿！你的破衬衫怎么回事？你的衬衫太蠢了。”然后我自己的衬衫还塞在裤子里。对吧？难道我们不都穿着几件蠢衬衫吗？
Do you still live in Tennessee?
Yeah.
I moved back.
So I was gone like 13 years.
And then we've been back for about nine.
Yeah.
I hear it's beautiful down there.
Yeah, it's so good, right?
你现在还住在田纳西州吗？对。我又搬回去了。我大概离开那里13年了。然后我们又搬回去大约9年了。对。我听说那里非常漂亮。对，真的很棒，对吧？
Yeah, I'm born and raised there.
It's great.
We have as much of a normal life as it can be.
We're living in a cul-de-sac.
The house at the top.
So we have the leaders.
And we set the tone for it.
I have a joke.
对，我在那里出生长大。这太棒了。我们过着尽可能正常的生活。我们住在一个死胡同里。在最顶端的那栋房子。所以我们是带头人。我们为那里定下了基调。我有个笑话。
I'll just like to say,
it's my new act, Russ,
and we do all in our coldest,
we do all the right things.
Like if someone pulls down there,
we're like,
what are you doing down our street?
Any car we don't know.
我只想说，这是我的新段子，拉斯，我们在死胡同里做所有正确的事。比如如果有人开车驶入那里，我们会说：“你们在我们这条街上干什么？”任何我们不认识的车。
We just run out.
You better get out of our courts.
I mean, just furious if they come down there.
Brothers and sisters growing up?
I have a younger brother,
a younger sister.
So you're the oldest of the three.
And do they,
我们都会跑出去。你们最好离开我们的地盘。我的意思是，如果他们开进那条街，我们会超级愤怒。有兄弟姐妹吗？我有一个弟弟，一个妹妹。所以你是三个孩子里最大的。他们……
do they,
are they finding you funny
all the time?
Or like,
yeah?
Yeah,
yeah,
my brother's like three years younger than me.
他们会觉得你一直都很有趣吗？还是说……对，对，我弟弟比我小三岁。
My sister's about 10.
I've talked about her
and it's special and,
uh,
she works for me now,
too.
So that's fun.
I mean,
我妹妹大概小10岁。我在特辑里谈到过她，而且……她现在也为我工作。所以这挺有意思的。我的意思是，
get yelled at by her.
I mean,
you got your whole family,
you got your sisters working for you.
And then you're on tour
with your mom and dad
and your aunt.
And,
被她大喊大叫。我的意思是，你把全家人都带上了，你妹妹在为你工作。然后你还和你的爸爸妈妈还有阿姨一起巡演。而且，
uh,
I mean,
cool, though.
That's cool.
It's pretty rad.
I don't think you've said this, but you have, sorry, do you have kids?
Yeah, I have an 11-year-old daughter.
Why, you're so nervous to ask him that, Jason.
不过，真的很酷。这太酷了。我想你之前没说过这个，你有……抱歉，你有孩子吗？对，我有一个11岁的女儿。天哪，你问得太紧张了，杰森。
By the way, he's married, he said he's not available.
One of the kids' ages?
I did say before, don't ask about if I have kids.
Oh, all right, I guess we're, okay.
Yeah, and I have one, 11-year-old daughter.
Oh, that's great.
11-year-old daughter.
And what does it seem like she's going to want to do with her life?
顺便说一句，他已经结婚了，他说他现在没空。孩子们多大了？我之前说过，不要问我有没有孩子。好吧，我想我们……好吧。对，我有一个11岁的女儿。哦，太棒了。11岁的女儿。看起来她以后想做什么呢？
Does she want to...
She loves horses right now for some.
So I don't know why.
Oh, that sounds expensive.
That's expensive.
It is.
I don't, but I don't know where,
no one,
她想……她现在不知怎么特别喜欢马。所以我也搞不懂为什么。噢，听起来很花钱。那可真贵。确实。我不知道，但我不知道在哪，没人，
we don't come from horse stuff, you know?
You're not,
you're not horse people?
No,
there's never horse people,
but,
uh,
she loves horses.
我们又不是搞马术这行的，你知道吗？你们不是，你们不是那种跟马打交道的人？对，从来都不是，但是，呃，她很喜欢马。
So right now she's kind of doing that stuff,
but she's very creative,
very funny.
And she,
you know,
uh,
will get me and my wife laughing a lot,
you know,
所以现在她就在搞那些东西，不过她非常有创造力，非常搞笑。而且她，你知道的，呃，总是能把我和我老婆逗得哈哈大笑，你知道的，
and like,
I think I got to teach her where,
to where the joke,
you got to be like,
all right,
well,
you got to be serious.
Yeah,
然后，我觉得我得教教她，在什么时候，这个笑话，你得表现得像，好吧，你得严肃点。对，
isn't that funny?
It's like there's,
There's the age when they learn sarcasm, they learn humor,
but they don't yet know when to stop the joke.
They don't know when to do the joke.
But you don't want to shame them because you don't want to kill their spirit
or their sense of humor, so you just got to kind of grin and bear with so many things
in their life.
这不是很搞笑吗？就好像有那么个年龄，他们学会了讽刺，学会了幽默，但他们还不知道什么时候该适可而止。他们不知道什么时候该开玩笑。但你又不想羞辱他们，因为你不想扼杀他们的灵气或幽默感，所以你只能对他们生活中的许多事情付诸一笑，多多包容。
It's so incredible watching kids learn things that we forgot that we learned.
You know, like it's amazing.
You know nothing until you learn it.
She can make fun of her friends.
recent and like I think but then they all got like it it was like they did not like it was like
and it was funny I forget what it was but it was like it was something funny but you're like all right
you got to understand you're like you got to some people will be able to handle it like you know
she just is all about the joke because it's obviously just our you know her grandfather's a magician
看着孩子们学习我们已经忘记自己曾经学过的东西，真的是太不可思议了。你知道的，就这感觉太神奇了。在你学会之前，你什么都不懂。她会拿她的朋友开玩笑。最近，而且我觉得，但后来他们都觉得，就像，他们好像很不高兴，就好像，而且挺搞笑的，我忘了当时是什么事了，但就好像，是一件挺逗的事，可你会觉得，好吧，你得明白，你会觉得，有些人可能能接受，你知道的，她就是满脑子都是笑话，因为很显然，我们，你知道的，她爷爷是个魔术师，
comedian like so it's it's a lot of joking I think yeah I think that making fun of your friends is
is not a good path to go down.
It's not...
Unless it's Sean.
I mean, it's such a big button to hit.
No, I thought we were talking about friends.
Yeah, Sean is...
喜剧演员之类的，所以有太多的玩笑了，我觉得，对，我觉得拿朋友开玩笑并不是一条好的发展路线。这不对……除非对象是肖恩。除非对象是肖恩。我是说，这真是一个太明显的槽点了。不，我以为我们在聊朋友。对，肖恩是……
Oh, right.
You know what I mean?
You feel warm inside.
Where's that...
What's after Syracuse?
Where do you go next?
Albany.
So we started in...
噢，对。你知道我的意思吗？你心里觉得暖洋洋的。那接下来……锡拉丘兹之后是什么？你们接下来去哪？奥尔巴尼。所以我们从……
Of course.
Yeah, I was in.
And just fucks connected to you?
Like, what are you doing, dude?
Yeah, this is the route.
I know we started...
Last night we were in Philly at the...
Far...
当然。对，我当时在。怎么他妈的扯到你身上了？老兄，你在搞什么鬼？对，这就是这条路线。我知道我们开始……昨晚我们在费城的……远……
It was where the Sixers play.
No way.
It was this big thing.
And then it goes Syracuse and then it'll go Albany.
And then these are the two the Falun wanted to come to with Syracuse and Albany.
Yeah, of course.
That's a big, those are big venues.
I think he's from up here.
那是76人队的主场。不会吧。那是个很大的场馆。然后去锡拉丘兹，接着去奥尔巴尼。这些就是法伦想去的两个地方，锡拉丘兹和奥尔巴尼。对，当然。那是很大的场馆，那些都是大场馆。我想他是这附近的人。
Yeah.
He is.
He's from upstate New York.
What arena or place are you playing tonight in Syracuse?
The, you know, the arena.
The carrier dome probably, right?
Is that what it is?
No.
对。他是。他是纽约州北部人。你们今晚在锡拉丘兹是在哪个体育馆或地方演出？就是那个，你知道的，那个体育馆。可能是卡RIER穹顶体育场吧，对吧？是那个吗？不是。
Yeah.
No, I've been to a game there.
That's like a huge.
I've been a basketball game there
You can fill it.
You can feel it.
It's like, people buy tickets that are like,
不是。对。不是，我去那里看过比赛。那是个超级大的地方。我去那里看过篮球比赛。那种氛围太震撼了。你真的能感受到。就那种，人们买的票，
I don't think they can see the court.
Right.
They're sitting like behind the court.
Would there be a crowd that's just too big for a comedy show?
It's just like, it needs to be a little bit more intimate.
Like 20,000 people is like right at the max maybe or no.
Yeah, I mean, it's all about how I can feel.
We have, like, you know, the arena is we have these big screens.
我觉得他们都看不到球场。对。他们坐在类似球场后面的位置。会不会有这样一种观众群体，对喜剧演出来说人数实在太多了？就好像，现场需要再稍微亲密温馨一点。比如两万人差不多就是极限了吧，还是说不是？对，我的意思是，这全取决于我能调动怎样的感觉。我们有，就像，你知道的，体育场里有那些大屏幕。
We have, I've put more speakers up so everybody can hear it.
You really do try to make it intimate.
I mean, you can tell everybody gets real quiet.
I mean, that's the cool.
It's one of the coolest things is when you're telling a joke and you're this many people
are quiet.
Yeah, right.
You know, and this kind of, and they're just, I mean, you could, I could yell with no
我们有，我加装了更多的扬声器，这样每个人都能听到。你确实在努力营造那种亲密感。我的意思是，你能看出每个人都变得非常安静。我的意思是，那真的很酷。最酷的事情之一就是，当你在讲笑话，而这么多人都安静地听着。对，没错。你知道的，而且这种，而且他们只是，我的意思是，我可以不用
microphone and the top person could hear me is it gets that quiet.
That's so cool.
So, yeah, I mean, I'd imagine if you did a stadium, you know, I could see it getting a little
loose.
Right.
You know, and we're in the middle, too, of an arena.
So I'm, it makes it a lot, I'm a lot closer to.
everybody.
麦克风大喊，坐在最高处的人也能听到我，现场就是能安静到这种程度。太酷了。所以，对，我的意思是，我能想象如果你去体育场演出，你知道的，现场可能会变得有点失控。没错。你知道的，而且我们在体育场的正中间演出。所以，我离每个人都近得多。
Do a hundred thousand, do a Honda.
Come on, hey.
Do a hundred.
Do the big house of Michigan.
Have you ever had a moment where you kind of scare yourself a little bit by thinking about all
the eyes that are looking at you and that they're not talking and that it is silent and
that you might not be doing well and you can't leave for another 45 minutes?
Are you scared of the eyes?
去搞十万人的演出啊，去搞本田中心那种。拜托，嘿。搞个十万人的。去密歇根大学的大房子体育场。你有没有过这样的一刻：想到所有这些目光都在看着你，而且他们都不说话，现场一片寂静，而你可能表现得并不好，并且在接下来的45分钟里你都无法离开，你因为这些目光而感到有点害怕吗？你害怕那些眼睛吗？
I mean, if you ever had a panic attack on a stage
and know that you can't leave for another hour?
Yeah, I mean, you've done it so long now that you're...
I mean, keep your knees bent.
It's happened to me.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, I've done it now.
It's like, yeah, I mean, you think about it.
我是说，你有没有在舞台上经历过恐慌发作，并意识到接下来一个小时你都无法离开？对，我的意思是，你演了这么久，你已经……我是说，保持膝盖微屈。这种事发生在我身上过。对，对，对。我是说，我现在演成这样了。这就好像，对，我的意思是，你会去想这些。
I had an SNL, like, a little bit when I did the monologue.
I was more nervous with the monologue because it's like stand up
and you're like, I'm supposed to be good at this.
And then you've got to kind of deliver the joke.
into the camera, but there's the crowd.
And so, like, it was very weird to deliver jokes to kind of a spot where no one's at.
Right.
And you're right on the heels of sitting, of standing back behind that flat, behind the band, right?
我在《周六夜现场》时有过这种感觉，当我在做独白的时候有点这种感觉。我对独白更紧张，因为这就像单口喜剧，而你会想，我本该擅长这个的。然后你还得把笑话抖进摄像机里，但现场还有观众。所以，这种感觉非常怪异，对着一个根本没人站着的地方抖笑话。没错。而且你刚从那个平面后面、乐队后面走出来，站在舞台边缘，对吧？
That little narrow little plank.
And the whole crowd is silent and they're counting down to that live moment to America.
Like, it becomes really tangible.
Like, you're not just live in front of, you know, you know, a crowd.
It's beaming across, you know, the planet.
Oh, yeah.
Like, it's real tangible there.
Yeah, you're like, I could say anything right now,
就踩在那块狭窄的小木板上。全场鸦雀无声，他们正在倒计时迎接那个面向全美直播的时刻。这种感觉变得非常真切。就好像，你不仅是当着现场观众的面直播，你知道的，你知道的。它正在向全球发射信号，你知道的。噢，对。就像，在那里感觉非常真切。对，你会觉得，我现在可以说任何话，
and they're going to hear it right now because it's live, you know.
Yeah, yeah.
Remember when, I used to remember, like, 20 jokes when I was a kid.
He used to love them.
And now I can only remember, like, one or two, but from back, no, they're not that great.
No, go to tell one, Jay.
Do you have any jokes?
Do you want to hear a guy to tell a joke inside out?
他们现在就能听到，因为这是直播，你知道的。对，对。还记得吗，我以前记得，我小时候能记住20个笑话。他以前特别喜欢这些。现在我只能记住一两个了，而且是从以前记下来的，不，它们其实也没那么好。不，讲一个吧，杰。你有什么笑话吗？你想听一个老套的笑话吗？
Go ahead.
I do get a little tripped up.
Do you have a joke from when you were a kid that you'll never forget?
You may not use it in your act, but it's just like just a classic that was one of your favorites?
Yeah, I didn't use it in my act.
You say you do?
I hang, no.
I didn't hang on to you're like, I kept it.
来吧。我确实有点磕磕绊绊。你有什么小时候的笑话是永远不会忘记的吗？你可能不会把它用在你的演出里，但它就像是一个经典，曾经是你的最爱之一？对，我没有把它用在我的演出里。你说你有？我挂了，没有。我没有把你的那种留着，我说我保留了。
I read a joke book when I was five, and I'm closing on it.
I remember the joke, it was, I said there was a joke book or something,
and there was a guy goes, wait, or there's a spy.
or there's a fly in my soup and then the waiter goes well don't worry the spider on your bread we'll get it
and there's a picture of a spider bed and so my dad always brings it i remember that joke and then my
dad brought it up because i would like i was explaining why the joke was funny to him and like kind of
going through it like here's why this is funny you know so that that that one was the first one but i
let it go do you guys have jokes from when you're a kid that you'll never forget one joke that's
我五岁时读过一本笑话书，我对它记忆犹新。我记得那个笑话，它是，我说了有一本笑话书什么的，然后有个家伙说，等等，或者说有个间谍。或者说我的汤里有一只苍蝇，然后服务员说，别担心，你面包上的蜘蛛会去搞定它的，旁边还有一幅蜘蛛在床上的插画。所以我爸总是提起这个，我记得那个笑话，然后我爸把它提起来是因为我想，就像我在向他解释为什么这个笑话好笑，然后就像顺着讲了一遍，就像是“看，这就是为什么这个好笑”，你知道的。所以那个是第一个，但我把它放下了。你们有没有小时候永远不会忘记的笑话，就那种适合讲出来的笑话？有没有哪个是你一想就能想起来的保留曲目？我年纪还很小的时候有一本笑话书。你现在也有一本笑话书，不过你继续说。那个是，其实一点都不好笑。我六岁的时候觉得挺好笑的。就像是，死人去你家都去哪儿？答案是起居室。
appropriate to tell?
Is there one like a go-to that you remember?
I had a joke book when I was really little.
You have a joke book now, but keep going.
It was, it's not funny.
It was funny when I was like six years old.
It's like, where do dead people go in your house?
And it was the living room.
（注：英文原集第121与122区块内容有部分错位重复，此处按原音频文本连贯翻译）
I have one which is like,
people always say that ballet is really hard to do.
And so I always say, just don't do it.
Yeah.
Oh, see, Nate laughed.
That was Sean's opening joke when he did stand-up.
And what is it...
This would probably be interesting for folks, including me.
我有一个笑话是这样的，人们总是说芭蕾舞真的很难跳。所以我总是说，那就别跳呗。对，哦，你看，内特笑了。那是肖恩做单口喜剧时的开场笑话。而且这是什么……这对于大家来说可能挺有趣的，包括我在内。
What are the...
How do you do the economics of being a stand-up?
I'm assuming you have to bear all the costs of the trucks
and the infrastructure and all that stuff,
and then you get to keep whatever you don't spend
on what it costs to put the show up, right?
And you're making your money based on ticket sales
and merchandise, perhaps, full stop.
做单口喜剧的经济账是怎么算的？我假设你必须承担卡车、基础设施以及所有这些东西的所有成本，然后你可以留下扣除举办演出成本后剩余的所有收入，对吧？你的收入完全是基于门票销售和周边商品，或许就是这样，句号。
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, merch is not
merch is not the biggest thing in stand-up.
Why?
Yeah, I don't know.
I mean, we've had it.
We've done it at shows,
and it's just, it's not like a concert
对，对。我的意思是，周边商品并不是单口喜剧里最赚钱的大头。为什么？对，我不知道。我是说，我们有卖过。我们在演出里卖过，但它就是，它不像演唱会，
or people don't.
Like I'm saying, like, stand-up's still kind of,
it's kind of a newer thing.
Like, Cosby's like one of the first, he's still alive.
And, like, you know, like, he knew Lenny Bruce.
And then Carl.
Don't, you got to, if I could give you one piece of advice.
If we could just lose the Cosby references.
或者说人们不怎么买。就像我说的，单口喜剧依然算是一种，算是一种比较新的东西。比如，科斯比就像是第一批人之一，他还活着。而且，你知道的，就像，他认识兰尼·布鲁。然后是卡尔。别这样，你得，如果我能给你一条建议的话。如果我们能少提点科斯比。
If we could get it down to,
Boy, if we could get it down a single digit
to it would be great.
Yeah.
You know what?
Louis K.
I'm going to send you a couple articles.
Harvey Weinstein and I once set up an LLC.
如果我们能把它减少到，天哪，如果我们能把它减少到个位数那就太好了。对。你知道吗？路易·K。我要给你发几篇文章。哈维·韦恩斯坦和我曾经一起成立了一家有限责任公司。
But so you've got this huge...
Apparathus.
Yeah, apparatus, right?
But you know, you could do it without it.
But you get like a deal.
So you have promoters.
And then the...
Yeah, you are...
所以你拥有这么庞大的……一套班底。对，一套班底，没错。但你知道，你没有它也能演。不过你会签个协议。所以你有演出推广人。然后那个……对，你是……
I think the...
It's like the promoter is the one that's putting the money for like the the renting of the venue.
Right.
And then I'm paying, then it comes out of mind of the show budget of the speakers and all that stuff.
And so you can you can have it go as low or as big as you want it to go.
Who's your manager?
Who are your peeps?
Brillstein.
我觉得……这就好像推广人是那个出钱租赁场地的人。没错。然后我付钱，这笔钱从我的演出预算里出，包括扬声器和所有这些东西。所以你可以让制作规模按你的意愿可大可小。谁是你的经纪人？你的核心团队是谁？布里尔斯坦。
They're the...
Brillstein and UTA.
Yeah.
We'll be right back.
All right.
Back to the show.
By the way, backing way up to the beginning of this interview,
What is Bargazzi?
他们是……布里尔斯坦和UTA。对。我们马上回来。好的。回到节目中。顺便说一句，把话题扯回这次采访的刚开始，巴加齐（Bargazzi）是什么？
What is the nationality of Bargazzo?
It's Italian.
Oh, it is.
First of all, don't spit it out like that.
No, like, what the fuck is Hayes?
The fucking, son of it.
Sorry, Nate.
Jesus is he.
巴加佐（Bargazzo）是什么国籍的？是意大利的。哦，原来是这样。首先，别像那样吐出来。不是，我是说，海斯他妈的到底是什么？他妈的，这家伙的儿子。抱歉，内特。天哪，他是。
I mean, I knew it.
By the way, what the fuck is Bargast?
I just never heard of it.
This has really been a B in my bonnet for a minute.
How do you even spell that?
I know.
I can't even begin to spell it.
I kind of, I knew that, but I forgot that I knew that.
我的意思是，我本来就知道。顺便说一句，巴加斯特（Bargast）他妈的到底是什么？我只是从没听说过这个词。这真的像一根刺一样扎在我心里好一会儿了。这到底怎么拼？我知道。我甚至根本不知道怎么拼它。我其实，我知道这个，但我忘了我知道这个。
Italian.
I think we say it wrong as a family, too.
I think it's supposed to be Bargazzi, and we say Bargots.
Like, it's just we've southerned it up.
Oh, I say Bargotsie.
Yeah, I think a lot of people would.
Don't people say Bargotsie?
When I lived in New York, they would always be like,
意大利语。我觉得我们家也把它读错了。我觉得它本来应该是“Bargazzi”，而我们读成“Bargots”。就像，我们把它给南方化了。哦，我读的是“Bargotsie”。对，我觉得很多人都会这么读。难道人们不读“Bargotsie”吗？我住在纽约的时候，他们总是会说，
Bargotsie, because it's like Italian, and I was like, you know.
Baggots.
I was like, I don't like tomatoes.
Do you have family in Italy?
I don't, you know.
You don't know. Yeah.
I think we've all agreed to kind of go.
We had a family union once, and we had family come over from Italy,
“Bargotsie”，因为这听起来像意大利语，而我就像，你知道的。巴加茨（Baggots）。我就像，我不喜欢西红柿。你在意大利有亲戚吗？我没有，你知道的。你不知道。对。我想我们都同意就这么算了吧。我们有一次办过家族聚会，我们有意大利来的亲戚，
and we got Kentucky Fried Chicken for them.
And I think it was like from that moment
was just kind of like, all right, y'all have a good life.
We did it.
We're going to do y'all's thing.
And we've just got to go on our separate ways.
Nate, what do you like to do in your free time?
And you've got a lot of time like on a bus
我们给他们买肯德基炸鸡吃。然后我觉得大概就是从那一刻起，感觉就像是，好吧，祝你们生活愉快。我们尽力了。我们要按你们的那套来。然后我们就各奔东西了。内特，你喜欢在空闲时间做什么？你有很多时间，比如在巡演大巴上，
or you're touring or on the plane or whatever.
What do you watch?
What are the things?
Are you a sports guide?
Do you watch other stand-ups?
Is it a candy crush?
How are you occupying your minutes?
Yeah, I'm a big sports guy
或者在巡演中，或者在飞机上什么的。你都看什么？有哪些东西？你是体育迷吗？你看其他单口喜剧演员的演出吗？是玩糖果粉碎传奇（Candy Crush）吗？你是怎么打发时间的？对，我是个超级体育迷，
So I watch a lot of golf
Like any sports golf, UFC
Wons La UFC
Oh, you do?
Yeah, I'm a big fan of UFC
I wanted to peg that
I wanted to peg you for a big good kid
It's just the most I
所以我会看很多高尔夫比赛，任何体育运动都看，高尔夫、UFC、温网，还有UFC。哦，你真的看？对，我是UFC的超级粉丝。我想把这一点挑出来讲，我想把你归类为那种很棒的居家好孩子。这纯粹是因为那种我……
The honesty of it
With like Dana White
Just in the fighters
They can say whatever they want
And so there's no
You know like when Tom Brady
Is he go retire or not retire
It's like it's all kind of a game and a show
那种真实感，就像白大拿（Dana White）和那些格斗选手一样。他们想说什么就能说什么，所以没有，你知道的，就像汤姆·布雷迪（Tom Brady）是退役还是不退役，这就全都是一场游戏和秀。
And UFC
kind of really is like, we just got a dude that just says, I want to fight this guy.
Right.
And then it just gets to it.
And you're, I don't know, I kind of like, I love it.
But there's no romance to that, too, though, right?
Like, the kind of is the buildup to it.
And then they get in the, you know, then they don't like each other.
而UFC给人的感觉真的是，我们这里有个家伙直接说，我想跟这家伙打。没错。然后他们就直接开打了。而且你，我不知道，我挺喜欢，我太爱这个了。但这里面也没有什么浪漫色彩，对吧？就像那种赛前的造势过程。然后他们走上，你知道的，然后他们互相看不顺眼。
And then you're, you know, and then you go in there and watch them fight.
It's not just watching a street fight.
You're watching two professionals that have to, like, fill each other out.
Yeah.
So you watch, UFC, you watch golf.
You like to play golf.
You play golf when you're on the road?
Some.
然后你，你知道的，然后你走进去看他们打比赛。这不只是在看一场街头斗殴。你看到的是两个必须互相试探的专业选手。对。所以你看UFC，你看高尔夫。你喜欢打高尔夫。你在巡演路上也会打高尔夫吗？偶尔。
It gets hard.
but it's because of the shows and stuff
but yeah I'll play some on the road
yeah yeah yeah I mean
it's kind of it I mean I don't know it's like you're just
running around got a lot of hanging out like the road
is the most fun because it's just like a bunch of dudes
and you know this morning we went in Syracuse
这很难办，主要是因为演出之类的事，但对，我在巡演路上也会打一点，对，对，对。我的意思是，这差不多就是这样，我不知道，这就好像你到处奔波，有很多闲逛的时间，巡演路上是最有意思的，因为就是一帮大老爷们聚在一起，而且，你知道的，今天早上我们在锡拉丘兹，
in this place as a hot and cold plunge thing
sure and uh well love so I've never done it
and then so but they let us come in
so like we woke up and did that wait who's boo week
I saw something.
Oh, yeah.
What is that?
So this is another, I told it on that scene I'd tell it in my act too.
在这个地方有一个冷热交替浸泡浴的设施，当然，而且，呃，我们太喜欢了，我以前从来没试过，然后，但他们让我们进去，所以我们一醒来就去试了那个。等等，布·威克利（Boo Weekly）是谁？我刚才好像看到了什么。哦，对。那是什么？所以这是另一个，我在这场巡演里讲过，我也准备在我的演出里讲。
But it, Boo Weekly, because I have a joke about fighting orangutan at a county fair.
Okay.
And where I read the story was, there's a golfer named Boo Weekly.
And when he read, he said when he was 15, he got in, he goes to this county fair.
He's from like, like, Southern Georgia.
It's like the 80s.
you know, and you could pay $5 to fight an orangutan.
A rangatang would be in a boxing ring with boxing gloves.
但是，布·威克利，因为我有一个关于在乡村集市上跟猩猩打架的笑话。好吧。我读到这个故事的地方是，有个高尔夫球手叫布·威克利。他说他15岁的时候，他去了这个乡村集市。他来自佐治亚州南部那边。大概是80年代的事，你知道的，你可以花5美元跟一只猩猩打架。那只猩猩会戴着拳击手套在拳击擂台里。
And so dudes would pay $5 to fight them.
That's hysterical.
Yeah, and then guys would get in there,
and this ring would just knock people out.
Because what I said, I tell the whole story in my act,
but I say because we didn't have the Internet to look up how strong's in orangutangangangang.
It was all word of mouth back then.
So, you know, you had to meet a guy that just fought an orangutan.
所以小伙子们会花5美元跟它们打架。太搞笑了。对，然后有些家伙上去了，那个擂台会直接把人给打晕。因为我之前说过，我在我的演出里会讲整个故事，但我说是因为我们当时没有互联网去查一只猩猩到底有多大力气。那时候全靠口耳相传。所以，你知道的，你必须遇到一个刚跟猩猩打过架的家伙。
And he's like, he's stronger than you think.
You know, you're like, well, but the arms are so skinny.
You know, I know.
But the reach.
And the reach.
It's the reach.
It's the reach. It's the jab.
It's the feet.
然后他会说，它比你想象的要强壮。你知道的，你会想，好吧，但它的胳膊那么细。你知道的，我懂。但它的臂展。还有臂展。关键在于臂展。关键在于臂展。是它的刺拳。是它的步法。
It's bigger than you, yeah, that strength comes from somewhere.
And they'll rip your face off, too, if they want.
Well, that's what boo-weeeky said.
He goes, that's not written everywhere back in 1982 when you're fighting orangutan.
The guy that does this doesn't go all.
you sign a waiver.
Sure.
Yeah.
它比你体格大，对吧，那种力量是从某个地方来的。而且如果你惹毛了它们，它们甚至会把你的脸撕下来。好吧，布·威克利就是这么说的。他说，在1982年你跟猩猩打架的时候，这句话可不是到处都写着的。做这行的那个人才不会把所有……你得签一份免责声明。当然。对。
You don't realize until afterwards, like, that's why he has gloves on.
If it gets the gloves off, there's a chance it will rip your head off.
So, but, you know, what are you going to do?
Write the Scramble again?
Yeah.
That's really funny.
Oh, I wonder if that's still in existence anywhere in the country.
I bet there's still a place.
你直到事后才意识到，哦，这就是为什么它要戴手套。如果它把手套摘了，它随时有可能把你的头给撕下来。所以，但是，你知道的，你还能怎么办？再去赛马场重来一次吗？对。真的太搞笑了。哦，我在想全美还有没有哪里能看到这种东西。我敢打赌肯定还有这种地方。
So, I think Peter got a hold of a lot of this.
Yeah.
Sure.
They knocked those things down.
And that one, they were like, you can't do that.
We're like, all right, we thought they liked it.
I'm glad you just had to tell us, and we got rid of it.
Fair enough.
所以，我觉得善待动物组织（PETA）掌握了这其中的很多情况。对。当然。他们把那些东西都取缔了。然后那次，他们就说，你们不能这么干。我们就想，好吧，我们还以为他们挺喜欢呢。我很高兴你刚把这事告诉我们，然后我们就把它去掉了。也对。
Nate, what are you going to do today before the show?
Tell them you're busy.
It was this, and then, yeah, it was just this.
I don't have any.
I got to read where I'm messing up the order a little bit, so I'll do that a little.
And then we're just hang out and be at the venue.
if there's, we do try to shoot basketball, like some of these arenas,
if they have a basketball goal somewhere,
内特，你今天在演出前打算做点什么？告诉他们你很忙。就是这个，然后，对，也就是这些。我没有别的。我得读一下我把顺序弄乱了的那部分，所以我待会儿会弄那个。然后我们就在那儿闲晃，待在场馆里。如果有的话，我们确实会去投投篮，有些场馆里如果有篮球架的话，
we're trying to like mess around, do basketball,
just kind of, you know, do whatever until.
That's nice.
And then you're going on tour,
you've got a new special, you're shooting a new special.
In Phoenix, yeah.
You love Phoenix.
You love, you've taught, you did another,
我们会试着去胡闹、投投篮，就是那种，你知道的，随便干点什么直到……挺好的。然后你接下来要开始巡演，你有一个新的专场，你要录制一个新的专场。在菲尼克斯，对。你爱菲尼克斯。你爱，你聊过，你之前做过另一个，
you did your last special on Phoenix.
I did my last special there.
And this one's going to be in the footprint center where the suns play.
So it's, uh, it's, yeah, it's, it's, it's, it's,
Yeah, it's, it's, yeah, I mean, it just kind of works out, like, touring-wise.
Like, you just hit these towns, like, every two years or so.
And so it's just kind of like...
And your family goes with you, or do they stay home?
你的上一个专场就是在菲尼克斯做的。我的上一个专场就是在那里做的。而这次的专场将会在太阳队的主场足迹中心（Footprint Center）举行。所以，呃，它，对，它，对，它，对，它，对，我的意思是，这刚好在巡演安排上很合适。就像，你每隔两年左右就会去这些城市巡演一次。所以这就有点像……你的家人会跟你一起去，还是他们留在家里？
They do some.
Yeah, yeah, we went to Europe.
Like, they came to Europe.
They come to the, you know, they're not here in Syracuse or Albany.
But they, if they're going to, I'm doing the Boston Garden.
They're going to come to Boston.
Okay, yeah.
Tell them to join you out in Phoenix for some of the best pizza in the world,
他们会去一部分。对，对，我们去过欧洲。比如，他们去了欧洲。他们会去，你知道的，他们现在没来锡拉丘兹或奥尔巴尼。但他们，如果他们要来的话，我要去波士顿花园演出。他们会来波士顿。好吧，对。告诉他们在菲尼克斯加入你，去吃号称全世界最好吃的披萨，
as voted by the voters.
By the people.
At Chris Biancos.
Nate, can you do, I saw you do this one thing a long time ago.
You don't have to do it by if you're like, I got to go.
But one of the funniest things I ever saw you do.
Sorry, dude.
由选民们投票选出的。由大众投票的。克里斯·比安科（Chris Biancos）开的店。在克里斯·比安科那里。内特，你能做个表演吗？我很久以前看你做过这么一件事。如果你觉得“我得走了”，你也可以不做。但我看过的你做过的最搞笑的事情之一。抱歉，老兄。
You know me to stand up and do my act?
Do you mind?
Just show us your tits real quick and then go to show.
Would you mind doing it topless?
Sorry, show us your tits.
No, one of the funniest things was it was a story about your meeting, your wife's,
ex-boyfriend.
Yeah, on the boat?
你知道我是个单口喜剧演员，要做我的演出吗？你介意吗？给我们露一下你的胸，然后就去演出。你介意上半身全裸来做这个吗？抱歉，给我们看看你的胸。不，最搞笑的事情之一是一个关于你跟你的前女友——哦不，你老婆的前男友见面 的故事。对，在船上？
Yeah, yeah.
I went, yeah, we went, I got to remember it, but we went to, it happened, we're on the lake,
Old Hickory Lake.
Is that true?
Yeah, and we're in, we're like in the water, and then it's, my wife's ex-boyfriend was on
another boat.
Right.
And I didn't see him, and she pointed out, like, there's no reason to point it out.
对，对。我去，对，我们去，我得回忆一下，但我们去了，事情发生时我们在湖上，老山核桃湖（Old Hickory Lake）。真的吗？对，我们在，我们在水里，然后，我老婆的前男友在另一艘船上。没错。我没看见他，她指了出来——其实根本没必要指出来。
and she pointed it out.
So then, yeah, like, all I can think of it now, like, I'm thinking about him.
Like, and then I look at her and she's looking at him,
and I feel like she's looking at him to see what her life would be like if she didn't marry me.
Yeah.
And I was looking at him to see what my wife would be like if I didn't marry her.
Uh-huh.
So we're both putting a lot of pressure on this guy.
而她却把它指出来了。所以然后，对，就像，我现在脑子里全是他，我满脑子都在想他。然后我看着她，而她在看着他，我觉得她看着他是在想，如果她没有嫁给我，她的人生会是什么样。对。而我看着他是在想，如果我没有娶我老婆，我老婆的生活会是什么样。呃-huh。所以我们俩都把很大的压力压在这个家伙身上。
Yeah.
And then my buddy told me, he's like, you should go fight him.
And I was like, what, like, he's on a boat.
Like, I got to swim over to that fight.
Have you ever tried to climb in a boat from water?
It's not graceful.
It's not easy.
You don't come in with power.
对。然后我哥们跟我说，他觉得你应该去跟他干一架。我就想，什么，开玩笑吗，他在船上。我难道得游过去跟他打架吗？你有没有试过从水里爬上一艘船？那一点都不优雅。那可不容易。你根本使不上劲。
I would need his help to start the fight.
Right, right.
I think that was, yeah.
It's so funny.
But I just, I mean, we can all relate to meeting exes, you know, our current exes.
It's never good.
Yeah, I don't.
I don't really have exes.
我得需要他的帮助才能把架打起来。没错，没错。我觉得那是，对。太搞笑了。但我只是，我的意思是，我们都能感同身受那种遇到前任的感觉，你知道的，我们现在的那些前任。这从来都不是什么好事。对，我没有。我其实没有前任。
All right.
What are you talking about, Nate?
I know.
I didn't go.
I know,
but that's what made it frustrated.
I don't,
I had no one to go show my wife,
好吧。内特，你在说什么呢？我知道。我没去。我知道，但这就是让人沮丧的地方。我没有，我没有人能去指给我老婆看，
well, here's mine.
Yeah.
What do you mean?
What is she your high school sweetheart or something?
No,
we started dating like 20, 21.
We met at Applebee's.
We both waited tables at Appleby.
好吧，我的是这个。对。你什么意思？难道她是你高中青梅竹马什么的吗？不，我们大约在20、21岁时开始约会。我们在苹果蜂（Applebee's）认识的。我们俩都在苹果蜂当过服务员。
I was a host at the time.
Oh, that's great.
I love that.
You don't need to scream.
Yeah.
Well, stuff is going, you know.
Sounds like it's all good in the neighborhood or what are we?
Yeah, we're all in the neighborhood.
我当时是个迎宾员。哦，太棒了。我喜欢这个。你不需要尖叫。对。好吧，事情正在进行，你知道的。听起来一切都好，或者我们这是在哪个社区？对，我们都在这个社区。
We're in the neighborhood or something.
We're big fans.
We took our daughter.
What was your favorite thing on the Applebee's menu?
Here we go.
They did chicken broccoli Alfredo.
I'd get no broccoli, you know?
Yeah.
我们在社区里还是什么的。我们是超级粉丝。我们带了我们女儿去。你在苹果蜂菜单上最喜欢的东西是什么？来咯。他们做鸡肉西兰花阿尔弗雷多（chicken broccoli Alfredo）。我点的时候会说不要西兰花，你知道的？对。
Get that out of the area.
And then I'd say put it on the side just so the guy thinks I'm going to eat it.
Then he would just take a full plate of broccoli back after.
I got full on the other stuff.
That's so true.
Like we're worried what they think, yeah.
Yeah.
What's this?
把那个从盘子里拿走。然后我会说把它放在盘子边上，好让服务员觉得我会吃它。然后他最后会把满满一盘西兰花原封不动地端回去。我光吃别的东西就吃饱了。真的太真实了。就好像我们在乎他们怎么想一样，对吧？对。这是什么？
Do you think that's impressive?
Sean, Applebee's menu backwards.
Go.
Cobbler, Apple Cobbler.
Of those kinds of restaurants.
Chinese chicken salad?
Pretty good.
I'll eat that.
你觉得这让人印象深刻吗？肖恩，倒背苹果蜂的菜单。开始。苹果酥，苹果酥。在那种类型的餐厅里。中式鸡肉沙拉？挺不错的。我会吃那个。
Every place makes a Chinese chicken salad now.
That's kind of like the new, you know, molten lava cake.
Every place has a Chinese chicken.
What makes it a Chinese chicken salad?
It's just because of the ginger dressing?
They're the only ones that don't eat it.
No.
And those crispy noodles, the crispy noodles and the, yeah, you get the crispy...
现在每个地方都做中式鸡肉沙拉。这就有点像新的，你知道的，熔岩蛋糕。每个地方都有一款中式鸡肉沙拉。什么才叫中式鸡肉沙拉？难道就因为姜味沙拉酱吗？他们是唯一不吃这个的人。不对。还有那些脆面条，脆面条和，对，你吃那些脆……
Chin Chin.
No, listen, Sean, I don't have to tell you.
Chin Chin Chin.
Chin does the best one.
Yeah.
One of the best ones.
John's handling his chin chin, chin.
金金（Chin Chin）。不，听着，肖恩，我不用告诉你。金金，金。金金做的最好吃。对。最好吃的之一。最好吃的之一。肖恩在应付他的金金。
Wait, so of all those kinds of restaurants, I forget what you call them.
Are they big box restaurants?
No, chain restaurants.
Have y'all not been to one in a while?
Like, you got to just go.
It's been a minute, but I did like to see in your new special, Nate says everything.
everything I learned, I don't know a lot that came from a big, like a building, like a higher education building.
Everything I learned, I overheard a Target or a Lowe's.
等等，所以在所有这些类型的餐厅里，我忘了你们管它们叫什么。是大盒子餐厅吗？不，连锁餐厅。你们难道有一段时间没去过这种地方了吗？就像，你必须得去一次。虽然有一阵子没去了，但我确实喜欢在你的新专场里听内特说：我学到的一切，我不知道很多东西是来自于一个大楼，比如高等教育大楼。我学到的一切都是我在塔吉特（Target）或劳氏（Lowe's）偷听来的。
The Lowe's music, the line of Lowe's.
Everything I overheard.
Yeah, we're big chain.
I mean, I grew up, like, we're a, you know, I had an old joke about, like, I was a big, I don't like mom and pop shops because they can close.
Just they're like, we don't feel good today and they close.
Like, Walmart.
Walmart, you know, they were a mom and pop shop at some point.
and then they got it together and became unreal.
劳氏的音乐，劳氏的排队区。我听到的一切都是偷听来的。对，我们是大型连锁店的粉丝。我的意思是，我小时候，就像，我们是一个，你知道的，我以前有个老笑话是关于，我不喜欢夫妻老婆店，因为它们说关门就关门。它们就来一句“我们今天感觉不太好”然后就关门了。就像沃尔玛。沃尔玛，你知道的，它们在某个时期也曾是一家夫妻老婆店，
Yeah.
So.
I like those, too.
I like mom and Bob Scha.
Here's what I like.
I like chilies.
And I'm not afraid to say, I love.
然后它们把各方面理顺了，就变得牛逼轰轰了。对。所以。对。我也喜欢那些。我喜欢夫妻老婆店。我喜欢这样：我喜欢奇利斯（Chili's）。而且我毫不掩饰地说，我爱死那儿了。
They have the great chocolate lava cake.
If you want one, go to chilies.
Go to chili.
And they also have the great,
they used to have the southwest egg rolls or whatever.
They used to have those things.
Me and Dax used to always go to, God, I love a chilies.
What about Outback?
他们有超棒的巧克力熔岩蛋糕。如果你想吃一个，去奇利斯。去奇利斯。而且他们还有超棒的，他们以前有西南蛋卷什么的。他们以前有那些东西。我和戴克斯（Dax）以前总是去，天哪，我太爱奇利斯了。那澳拜客（Outback）呢？
Danny good with the Bloomingo.
Yeah, yeah.
We go to Outback a good bit.
Scotty.
Scotty worked at TGIF and he would have...
Oh, I used to love that.
That's good, too.
That's fun.
丹尼的秀色洋葱花（Bloomin' Onion）做得很好。对，对。我们经常去澳拜客。斯科蒂。斯科蒂在星期五餐厅（TGIF）工作过，他会有……哦，我以前最喜欢那个了。那个也很好。很有趣。
That's an intimidating menu.
Dr. Pepper's doing some pretty amazing things right now.
So if you are into Dr. Pepper,
died Dr. Pepper.
They got some real good stuff going on them.
And some cherry, right?
They got some, like some sort, like cream soda,
strawberry stuff.
那是一份让人看了眼花缭乱的菜单。博士胡椒（Dr. Pepper）现在正在搞一些相当惊艳的事情。所以如果你喜欢博士胡椒，健怡博士胡椒。他们现在有一些非常棒的产品。还有一些樱桃味的，对吧？他们有一些，比如某种奶油苏打水、草莓味的东西。
I mean, it's something, dude.
They're showing off over there.
Did we ever get any confirmation on the doctor portion of the pepper?
Like, did they, did we ever see,
documentation to prove that he graduated.
He suggests diet. What kind of doctor was he?
Yeah, I mean.
Dr. Poppe. He was a...
我是说，真的挺厉害的，老兄。他们在那边秀操作呢。我们有没有得到过关于胡椒博士那个“博士”头衔的任何证实？就像，我们有没有看过，能证明他毕业了的文件。他推荐健怡的。他到底算哪门子博士？对，我是说。波佩博士（Dr. Poppe）。他是个……
I do like Diet Dr. Pepper, too.
And I'm going to say this. I like their ads.
I like their TV ads.
Yeah.
I think they're funny.
I think you're right.
I think they're real clever.
Nate, before I let you go, how do you know Greg Garcia?
我也挺喜欢健怡博士胡椒的。而且我要说的是：我喜欢他们的广告。我喜欢他们的电视广告。对。我觉得挺搞笑的。我觉得你说得对。我觉得它们真的非常聪明。内特，在我让你离开之前，你是怎么认识格雷格·加西亚（Greg Garcia）的？
How did that happen? This son of a gun, speaking of a son of a guns.
So I've tried to make a bunch of shows that have never gone.
We've had one show that we shot a pilot.
And so Greg came in.
I did not know him, but he came in, Danielle Sanchez Whittsell.
She was a show running it, and she's friends with Greg.
And so Greg came in to help us do it.
And I knew Greg Garcia's work, but I didn't know him when he first came in.
这事是怎么发生的？这个混蛋，说到混蛋。所以我尝试过制作一堆没能播出的节目。我们有一个节目甚至拍过试播集。所以格雷格就加入了。我以前不认识他，但他加入了，丹妮尔·桑切斯-维特塞尔（Danielle Sanchez Whittsell）。她是那个节目的剧集运作人，她和格雷格是朋友。所以格雷格加入来帮我们制作。我知道格雷格·加西亚的作品，但他刚来的时候我不认识他。
So when he first came in, he's going to help us.
And I was like, I don't know who this dude is.
Yeah.
I got to listen to this guy.
And then we wrote our whole, rewrote the whole script on his, off just his ideas,
because they were so good.
And obviously he's unreal.
And so we just become really close and become friends.
所以当他刚来的时候，他是来帮我们的。当时我就想，我根本不知道这家伙是谁。对。我得听这家伙的。然后我们根据他的想法，完全重写了整个剧本，就因为他的点子太棒了。而且显然他牛得不行。所以我们俩就变得非常要好，成了朋友。
I was just with them this week, actually, at dinner with him.
Because I had to go to L.A. for a second.
And so he's, yeah, we became friends like that.
And he comes out on the road, too.
I'm telling you, y'all should, y'all come out on the road.
If you want to get away,
have a little fun trip.
Come on out.
其实我这周刚跟他一起吃过晚饭。因为我得去一趟洛杉矶待一会儿。所以他，对，我们就这样成了朋友。而且他也经常去巡演。我跟你说，你们俩真应该，你们俩也该去巡演路上看看。如果你想放松一下，来一次有趣的短途旅行。快来加入我们吧。
Dude, that would actually be really, really fun if you mean it.
It's a fun hang.
If you mean it.
Fallon's coming tonight.
We have a fun time.
You just play cards or you play, you know, like we went to a casino last night in Philadelphia.
Sean, I mean, first of all, this is your dream.
They go to casino and they're going to chain restaurants.
老兄，如果你是认真的话，那其实真的、真的会很有趣。那是个很好玩的地方。如果你是认真的话。法伦今晚要来。我们会玩得很开心。你们就是打打牌，或者玩，你知道的，我们昨晚在费城去了一家赌场。肖恩，我的意思是，首先，这就是你的梦想。他们去赌场，然后他们去连锁餐厅。
I mean, you know, every single, every cracker barrel has got to, got,
skin merchant from Sean's car.
Jack or Barrel is one we didn't touch on.
I've not been there, but I hear that's the one.
Anywhere that can handle bus parking, it's all changed.
Well, Greg Garcia is one of the all-time great guys,
super, super funny guy.
One of the funniest pranks.
我是说，你知道的，每一家，每一家粢饭树（Cracker Barrel）都得，都得贴着肖恩的车标。杰克·巴雷尔（Jack or Barrel）是我们没碰过的一个地方。我没去过那儿，但我听说那是必去之地。任何能停下大巴车的地方，全都是连锁店。好吧，格雷格·加西亚是有史以来最伟大的人之一，超级、超级搞笑的家伙。最搞笑的恶作剧之一。
He always, I'm not really like a big pranks guy,
but he is so funny, I had a long joke and a prank,
and I just, he's such a great guy.
So, yeah, that makes sense that you guys would be pals.
Well, listen, I'm going to return the offer and say next time you're out here in California,
let's go play golf, man, and hang out and grab some lunch.
Such a huge fan of yours, dude.
Honestly, you're just the funniest, funny as funny as funny as dude.
他总是，我其实不是那种热衷于恶作剧的人，但他太搞笑了，我有一个很长的笑话和一个恶作剧，而我只是觉得，他真的是个太棒的人。所以，对，你们俩能成为好朋友这就讲得通了。好吧，听着，我要投桃报李，说一句：下次你来加州的时候，咱们去打高尔夫球，老兄，然后一起闲逛，吃个午饭。我是你的超级粉丝，老兄。说真的，你就是最搞笑、最搞笑、最搞笑的家伙。
It's so good to see you.
So exciting to see you just more and more and more people.
Appreciate you.
Really happy for your success.
Truly, truly, truly.
Yeah, man.
Thank you.
Thanks for having me on.
很高兴见到你。看到越来越多、越来越多、越来越多的人喜欢你，真的太令人兴奋了。欣赏你。真心为你的成功感到高兴。千真万确。对，老兄。谢谢你。谢谢你邀请我来。
Nate, thank you for doing this.
What a thrill.
Thank you for saying.
All right, the great Nate Bergotsi.
Thank you, buddy.
Thank you, Nate.
Thanks, Nate.
内特，谢谢你来做客。太激动了。谢谢你这么说。太激动了。好的，伟大的内特·巴加齐。谢谢你，老兄。谢谢你，内特。谢谢你，内特。
Thank you, guys.
Bye, buddy.
Have fun.
Bye.
The great Nate.
God, is he funny?
谢谢你们。拜拜，老兄。玩得开心。拜拜。伟大的内特。伟大的内特。伟大的内特。天哪，他怎么这么搞笑？
Yep.
Olds, like, old school, clean, good, hilarious, nonstop fun.
Yeah.
God.
He just seems like a real kind fella, you know?
Yeah, I can't see him getting upset.
I'm sure you could figure out a way to piss him off.
How would you, what would be your strategy?
对。老派的、干净的、优质的、爆笑的、不间断的欢乐。对。天哪。他看起来就像个真正善良的家伙，你知道吗？对，我无法想象他生气的样子。我确信你肯定能找到办法惹毛他。你会怎么做，你的策略是什么？
Have you really wanted to get Nate pissed off?
I'd ask him with.
I'd ask him questions over,
I'd ask him the same thing over and over again,
like I didn't understand.
No, I think he'd be very patient with that.
I don't think that would be his button pusher.
No, like, no, but like if you,
如果你真的很想把内特惹毛呢？我会去问他。我会一遍又一遍地问他同样的问题，装作我听不懂的样子。不，我觉得他对此会非常有耐心。我觉得这不会是他的痛点。不，就像，不，但如果你，
if you just went on and on about something,
like you just really, honestly, truly didn't understand,
I think it pisses anybody off.
I wonder.
Like, what are you not getting, right?
Yeah, yeah.
You know what I mean?
No, we have a pretty high threshold.
如果你对某件事没完没了地追问，就好像你真的很诚实、真心实意地听不懂，我觉得这会惹毛任何人。我在想。就像，你到底哪里没听懂，对吧？对，对。你知道我的意思吗？不，我们的阈值挺高的。
Like, we have a pretty decent amount of patience for you in that regard.
What is the thing,
what is the thing that gets you?
you guys to anger quicker than anything else.
Stupidity.
People who don't think like I do.
I have a short fuse for stuff I, yeah, I don't suffer.
I have a short fuse for like, yeah, people who are incompetent or like can't, like,
比如，在这方面我们对你有相当不错的耐心。那是什么东西，到底是什么东西能让你们比什么都更快地感到愤怒？愚蠢。那些思维方式跟我不同的人。对于某些事我的耐心很短，对，我无法忍受。对于那些无能或者无法，就像，
like, like, don't have common sense about like easy things.
And then in the meantime, I'm the dumbest person on the planet and I probably do the same
thing.
Yeah.
I hate when, I hate when people like punch down, you know.
know, and they're like mean to people because they know they can be.
就像，对简单的事情缺乏常识的人，我没什么耐心。而与此同时，我却是地球上最笨的人，我可能也在干同样的事。对。对。对。我讨厌当，我讨厌当别人向下兼容地去欺负别人的时候，你知道的。而且他们对别人刻薄，因为他们知道自己可以这么做。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So lazy.
Yeah, yeah, it is.
Punch down either, especially if it, you know, we do do a lot of joking around and we love to sort of rip each other and stuff.
But anytime I see somebody who likes to, and we talked about with Nate, who likes to get a laugh at somebody else's expense.
Yeah, yeah.
Or you know what else that's pissing me off?
Confident ignorance.
对，对，对。太懒惰了。对，对，确实是。而且也不要向下欺负人，特别是，你知道的，我们确实开了很多玩笑，我们也喜欢互相恶搞之类的。但每当我看到有人喜欢，我们刚才也跟内特聊过，喜欢建立在别人的痛苦之上来博取笑声。对，对。或者你知道还有什么让我很火大吗？盲目自信的无知。
That can also be super funny though.
Yeah, sometimes.
Well, and the character it can be.
Right, you have to do it on purpose.
But yeah, a person who is much smarter or much more confident than they have a right to be is just grading.
Because you have to spend an effort to convince them that you're buying it.
Right.
But if you have no dog in that fight and you're just observing that person, it can be hilarious.
但那有时也超级搞笑。对，有时是的。好吧，作为一种人设来说确实可以。没错，你得是故意的。但是，对，一个比他有权自信的人聪明得多或自信得多的人，真的是令人厌烦。因为你必须付出努力去说服他们你是买账的。没错。但如果你跟那场争论毫无关系，而你只是在旁边观察那个人，那可能会非常搞笑。
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, that is true.
That is true.
By the way, I love playing them.
those characters.
Yeah, do you know.
The character that's just,
just an alpha everywhere.
哦，对。对，确实如此。确实如此。顺便说一句，我喜欢扮演那些角色。对，你知道的。那种在任何地方都表现得唯我独尊的角色。
And then the tough guy walks in
and then they're beta.
Yeah, yeah.
Right, right, right, right.
Exactly.
But Nate, we should go see his show
when he's out.
He's so funny.
然后那个狠角色走进来，他们就秒变小绵羊了。对，对。没错，没错，没错，没错。正是如此。不过内特，等他来演出时我们应该去看他的秀。他太搞笑了。
I think we should meet him in Phoenix
and go get some of that Bianco pizza.
We should, and then play some golf over there.
You know, you're not playing golf anymore.
Not until October.
That's not time.
I have to be disciplined, you know.
I know.
我觉得我们应该在菲尼克斯跟他在那儿碰面，去吃点那种比安科披萨。我们应该去，然后在那里打几场高尔夫。你知道的，你已经不打高尔夫了。直到十月之前都不打。现在不是时候。我得有自律性，你知道的。我知道。
I mean, we can go, we can go,
to Nate's.
There it comes.
We can go to his show and like participate or we can go and just be a bunch of bystanders.
Bye.
So dumb when we do.
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Arvajarv and Bennett Barbico.
我的意思是，我们可以去，我们可以去，看内特的演出。高潮来了。高潮来了。我们可以去看他的演出并参与互动，或者我们可以去当个纯粹的看客。拜。Smartless（聪明绝顶）节目由迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）、罗布·阿尔瓦贾夫（Rob Arvajarv）和贝内特·巴比科（Bennett Barbico）100%纯天然手工打造。
Smart.
Less.
聪明。绝顶。